ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE HEARING A FEW
REMINDERS MASKS ARE REQUIRED IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND OTHER
COMMON AREAS THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITAL TESTIMONY CAN BE
PROVIDED IN PERSON AND BY PHONE
THE NUMBER FOR PHONE TESTIMONY
IS. 877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
FOUR FOUR. THIS NUMBER IS POSTED
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AND
ALSO APPEARS ON THE VIDEO FEED.
ONCE THE PRIMARY SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES HAVE
TESTIFIED FOR EACH BILL I WILL
CALL FOR A DISPOSITIONAL
TESTIMONY STARTING WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE ROOM THEN
GOING TO THE PHONES. PLEASE NOTE
THAT ITEM TWELVE AB THREE OH
THREE- BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR. WE HAVE THIRTEEN
MEASURES ON THE AGENDA TODAY
WITH THREE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT
ITEM ONE AB SIX FORTY NINE ITEM
NINE AB THREE FIFTY THREE. AND
ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWELVE FORTY.
PLEASE NOTE THAT MR BENNETT HAS
BEEN APPOINTED TO FILL THE
VACANCY TODAY AND MISS RAY YES
HAS BEEN APPOINTED TO REPLACE
MISS FRIEDMAN FOR TODAY. BEFORE
WE BEGIN HEARING OF BILLS I'D
LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
RECOGNIZE STAFF WE'RE PLEASED TO
WELCOME MARK THE GOOD THE
ADDRESS AS OUR NEW COMMITTEE
SECRETARY SHE'S SITTING RIGHT
HERE TO THE LEFT WELCOME. MARTHA
BRINGS A WEALTH OF EXPERIENCE
FROM THE SENATE MOST RECENTLY AS
COMMITTEE ASSISTANT FOR THE
SENATE LABOR COMMITTEE AS WERE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE HER JOIN OUR
TEAM WILL WELCOME. BUT SHE HAS
REPLACE SCENE- SUE FISHBACK
DAVIS WHO RETIRED DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST AFTER OVER THIRTY
YEARS OF SERVICE TO THE STATE.
THE COMMITTEE WAS PRIVILEGED TO
HAVE SU SERVICE THESE PAST FOUR
YEARS WHERE SHE SERVED UNDER
CHAIRS CRISTINA GARCIA. AL
MURATSUCHI LAURA FRIEDMAN AND
MYSELF. SUE'S WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE CAPPED OFF A
DISTINGUISHED CAREER WITH
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL THE
INTEGRATED WASTE MANAGEMENT
BOARD AND THE SENATE. SUE HAS
JOINED US TODAY AND I WANT TO
PERSONALLY THANK HER AND WISH
HER WELL IN HER RETIREMENT THANK
YOU SEE YOU. BOB. IF ANYONE ON
THE COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO ADD
COMMENTS OF MACHINES TO RETIRE
WITH DIVERSITY YES
CONGRATULATIONS TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR MANY YEARS OF
SERVICE IS ALWAYS A- YOU KNOW
YOU YOU SUCH A- A PLEASANT
CALMING PRESENCE- IN THE
COMMITTEE- THEN AND SO ARE YOU.
NO WAS TO THE BATH. OKAY SO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO JOIN US- ONE
LAST TIME- WE HAVE A RESOLUTION
TO PRESENT TO YOU- AND WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR YEARS OF
SERVICE AND FOR ALL THE HELP. OF
THAT YOU PROVIDED TO THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE. YOU WANNA
YEAH YES TO A NETWORK OF LOCAL
THE THIRD. THANK YOU SO MUCH. I
HAVE A. SUCH AS A FOLLOW UP
HELLO. PLEASE YOU SAID YOU HAVE
A FEW WORDS OF FEES. THIS IS MY-
HEALTH YEAH. MADAM CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU FOR THIS RESOLUTION
AND FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
PRESENT TO. AND THANK YOU TO MY
COMMITTEE STUFF. AND ALL THOSE
INVOLVED IN DRAFTING AND
PREPARING IT IT REALLY MEANS A
LOT TO ME. I HAVE MY HUSBAND
STEVE HERE WITH ME. WE'RE
NEWLYWEDS- YEAH WE MET ONLINE
AND- MAY TWENTY NINETEEN RIGHT
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC IT. BERMAN
DURING THE PANDEMIC FROM HOME
RUN OUR SECOND MARRIAGE. NEVER
THAT WOULD MERIT AGAIN. THE REAL
REASON I'M RETIRING ONE YEAR
EARLY- BETWEEN US WE HAVE SEVEN
BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN AND ELEVEN
WONDERFUL GRANDCHILDREN- THEY
CAN BE HERE WITH ME SO BECAUSE
OF THE VIRUS THERE WATCHING FROM
HOME- I JUST WANT TO SAY I'M
REALLY PROUD OF MY CIVIL SERVICE
AND I'M GRATEFUL TO HAVE SPENT
WORKING IN THE LEGISLATURE. I'VE
WORKED VERY HARD. SOMETIMES ON
LITTLE SLEEP DURING LEGISLATIVE
DEADLINES AN END OF SESSION. BUT
I SURE HAD A LOT OF FUN AND
LAUGHS AND GOOD TIMES WORKING
WITH A BUNCH OF AMAZING. FUNNY
VERY SMART PEOPLE I ALWAYS LOVE
MY JOB. I AM HONORED AND
PRIVILEGED TO HAVE WORKED FOR
AND WITH ALL OF YOU. THE MOMENT
YOU AND YOUR STAFF- MUCH. I'LL
STEVEN ARE GONNA BE OUT.
ENJOYING THE ENVIRONMENT
WILDLIFE. IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WE'VE ALL WORKED SO HARD TO
PROTECT AND KEEP CLEAN. SO THANK
YOU. KEEP UP THE GOOD WORK. AND
GOD BLESS. THANK YOU THROUGH. I
GET CALL THE ROLL OVER MONSTER.
I KNOW IF YOU WANT TO STAY IN
CALL THE ROLL ONE LAST TIME THIS
IS LIKE NO IRONY RETIRED. THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TODAY- WE ALSO HAVE A CHANGE IN
THE CONSULTANT POSITION- WITH
MICHAEL JARED DEPARTING THIS
PAST FALL TO START A CONSULTING
VENTURE. I WANT TO THANK MICHAEL
FOR HIS SIX YEARS WITH THE
COMMITTEE. AS WELL AS WELCOME
OUR NEW CONSULTANT PAGE BROKAW
WHO WILL BE STARTING STARTING
NEXT WEEK WITH US- NOW WE'RE
READY TO TURN TO THE FIRST ITEM
ON THE AGENDA. BUT I BELIEVE
MISTER BENNETT IS NOT HERE SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD. AND GO WITH MR
FONG. WHAT ITEM IS- TOTEM THREE
EIGHTY FIVE ITEM THREE AB FIVE
TWO TWO. BUT WE- I'M SORRY I
HAVEN'T ALSO SORRY YEAH I NEED
TO I HAVE AN ESTABLISHED KERR
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS FOR
REMINDING ME- SECRETARY CAME
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS. HERE RIVAS HERE
FLOOR. FLOOR HERE BENNETT.
GARCIA. MATHIS MATHIS HERE
MCCARTY THIRTY HERE MARRIAGE TO
CHEAP MURATSUCHI HERE RATE THIS
YEAR REYES HERE ZERO. STONE YEAH
STONE HERE WOULD. BUT HERE WE
HAVE WHAT OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM
SO NOW WE'RE READY FOR THE BILL
PRESENTATION ITEM THREE I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS WOULD
FIRST LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND I
THANK THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE. CERTAINLY
CAST A COOPER HAVE DEVASTATED
HOMES ENTIRE COMMUNITIES AND
SADLY BY THE BEEN LOST REDUCING
FUELS AND PROPERLY MANAGING
FORCE LANDS ARE PROVEN METHODS
OF PREVENTING FUTURE FIRES
WITHOUT THE HELP OF PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS THE STATE WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO MAXIMIZE FORCE HEALTH
AND WELFARE RESILIENCE. THIS IS
CRITICAL IF THE STATE IS GOING
TO MEET ITS ANNUAL GOAL OF
TREATING FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES TO PREVENT WILDFIRES
BEFORE HARVESTING TIMBER ON
PRIVATE LAND LAND OWNERS MUST
SUBMIT A TIMBER HARVESTING PLAN
PREPARED BY PROFESSIONAL
FORESTERS FIVE EIGHT BY
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL
FORESTERS THAT OUTLINED THE SIZE
SCOPE LOCATION AND METHOD OF THE
HARVEST HOWEVER LANDOWNERS MAY
BE EXEMPT FROM THIS REQUIREMENT
IF THE TIMBER HARVEST REDUCES
THE RATE. DURATION FIRED AGAIN
BILL FIRED MISSION AND INTENSITY
OF FIRE SPREAD THE CURRENT FORCE
FIRE PREVENTION PILOT PROJECT
EXEMPTION HAS ENABLED PRIVATE
FOREST LANDOWNERS TO CONTRIBUTE
TO THE STATE'S MISSION OF
PREVENTING FUTURE FIRES AND
DAMPENING THEIR INTENSITY
WITHOUT THE EXTENSION OF THE
PROGRAMFORCED THAT CAN TO BE
GRAFT AND BUILD WITH IT AND.
THIS DATE OF THE PILOT. AB FIVE
TWO ONE POWER LAND OWNER TO SAY.
INCREASE THE PACE AND SCALE OF
HEALTHY FORCE MANAGEMENT AND
HELP CALIFORNIA ACHIEVE ITS FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE GOAL
ACTUALLY LET. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL WHO. HEY THANK YOU I
BELIEVE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF BUT
THERE ARE TWO WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION- I HAVE DANIEL BROAD
FROM THE SIERRA CLUB AND BRIAN A
WIKI FOR THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY- BOTH WILL.
ARE ON THE PHONE TO TESTIFY-
OPERATOR. DO WE HAVE THOSE
WITNESSES READY. ABOUT.
YEAH
OPERATOR ARE YOU JUST CHECKING
IN TO SEE IF THE OPERATOR IS
READY AND HAS THE WITNESSES FOR
ITEM THREE AB FIVE TWO TWO.
OKAY. OKAY WE WANTED TO SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM SO FAR
OKAY SO I'M GONNA- WHILE WE WAIT
FOR THE TECHNICAL ISSUES TO BE
RESOLVED- I'M GONNA MOVE ON AND
SEE IF THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM FOR. AB FIVE TWO TWO. I
DON'T SEE ANY OKAY THANK YOU.
THE FACT. YEAH YEAH. IT IS ON OR
NOT. AND I CAN HEAR THE. YEAH.
USUALLY ASSEMBLY ENGINEER.
REMEMBER WE ARE. YOU CAN CLEAR
HIS NAME WE CAN'T. YEAH EMPIRE
NAY INTERRUPTION THIS IS THE
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR I CAN HEAR
THANK CONVERSATION IN THE
BACKGROUND. OKAY WE CAN HEAR YOU
NOW I ASSUME THAT MEANS THAT THE
ISSUE HAS BEEN RESOLVED BETTER.
YES MADAM CHAIR AYE AYE IF YOU
CAN HEAR ME YES I BELIEVE WILL
WILL BE ABLE TO A NEW SHADE-
THE- CONFERENCE ON OUR END OKAY
GREAT NEW TESTAMENT. THANK YOU
SO WE ARE READY FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE TWO TWO
ITEM THREE. WE HAVE TO WE SHOULD
HAVE TO. OPERATOR ARE YOU STILL
ON THE LINE. WE ARE STILL ONLINE
HEREBY APOLOGIES FOR THE FOR THE
ISSUES WHO HAD HER YOUR LINES
ARE ALL ACTIVE NOW. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE THANK YOU.
OPERATOR.
PARDON THE INTERRUPTION AGAIN
THIS IS THE EIGHTEENTH OPERATOR
WE HAD BIG LIVE LINE AND- WE'VE
LOST THE LIVE LINE AGAIN. OKAY
DO YOU KNOW HOW LONG IT'LL TAKE
TO GET GET A BAD MADAM CHAIR
PARDON ME I CAN HEAR YOU CLEARLY
NOW. OKAY WE ARE WAITING FOR THE
WITNESSES. YOU MAY CALL THEM BY
NAME MADAM CHAIR. DANIEL VARADA
AND BRIAN NO WIKI. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS DANIEL BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE TWENTY
TWO WHICH WOULD EXTEND THE
FOREST FIRE PREVENTION EXTENSION
. THE POOREST PRESS FIRE
PREVENTION EXEMPTION IN THE
TIMBER HARVEST PLAN EXEMPTION
THAT ALLOWS FOR TREES TO BE
REMOVED WITHOUT AND FIREMEN OR
B. L. T. H. P. AND ARE INTENDED
TO ENSURE THAT LOGGING
OPERATIONS. DO NOT DAMAGED
ECOSYSTEMS WILDLIFE OR WATER
QUALITY. WITHOUT T. H. B. TO
REMOVAL OPERATIONS HAVE THE
POTENTIAL FOR SUBSTANTIAL AND
EXTENSIVE DAMAGE TO FORSAKE.
WILDLIFE HABITAT. BOILS DOWN AND
WHY AND- BUT REASONS WE OPPOSE
THIS EXEMPTION WHEN I WAS
ORIGINALLY BY THE LEGISLATURE IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND WE
MUST OPPOSE THE EXTENSION.
ACTING COMMUNITIES AND PERFECT
FOR SPEAKER SYSTEMS AND
MITIGATING WILDFIRES WILL TAKE
FULL COORDINATED PLANNING. THP
IS SHOULD BE VIEWED AS AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THE PLANNING
PROCESS THEN SHARED STORAGE
PROJECTS DO NOT HAVE UNINTENDED
AND COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
CONSEQUENCES RATHER THAN AS
IMPEDIMENTS TO THIS PROJECT AB
FIVE TWENTY TWO RUNS COUNTER TO
THE PURPOSES OF THE FACT THAT.
COMMUNITY PROTECTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION WITH
DANGEROUS IMPLICATIONS ABOUT. WE
OPPOSE THIS BELL AND ACTOR AND
HELP OUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I'M NEXT- WE HAVE BRIAN NO WIKI. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME BRIAN WE KEY
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
I'M LOOKING AT THAT TECHNICAL
HANG UP IS JUST SHAKING OFF THE
DUST. OF LAST YEAR AS WE GET
INTO THIS NEXT YEAR I COULD SEE
THAT COULD CARRY OUT THIS
AFTERNOON- YES I AM ALSO
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO A. B.
FIVE Q. TWO- I UNDERSTAND THE
INTENTION. OF THE BILL BUT I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT AFFECTED.
FIRE PREVENTION IS POSSIBLE ONLY
WITH PLANNING. AND THAT'S TO
FACT ABOUT THAT PROVIDE.
CONNECTION ACROSS PROPERTIES AND
COORDINATION SO THAT THOSE
VARIOUS PROJECTS HAPPEN. IN
TIMING THAT MAKES SENSE TO
PROVIDE FOR FIRE PREVENTION
PREVENTION IT FEELS PROJECTS
WHICH HAVE A LIMITED LIFESPAN
WHEN THEY'RE IMPLEMENTED ON THE
GROUND HAS TO BE DONE IN A
COORDINATED WAY TO BE EFFECTIVE
BOTH SPATIALLY AND IN TIME I
DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT THE PILOT
PROJECT WAS TO ALLOW NUMBER OF
PROJECTS TO GO THROUGH IN A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME WITH OUR
LEAD TIME OF SOME OF THAT
PLANNING- BUT- AN EXTENSION.
MAKING THIS PERMANENT AND THE
CONTINUING TO GO FORWARD WITHOUT
HAVING WITHOUT ALLOWING FOR THIS
PLANNING BOTH TO PROTECT THE
RESOURCES AND TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
ACHIEVING THE GOALS- WORKS NOT
ONLY DOES THAT MAKE SENSE AND
ISN'T NECESSARY BUT IT ACTUALLY
WORKS AGAINST THE INTENTIONS. OF
ACTIVE FIRE PREVENTION FOR THESE
REASONS AND STANDING WITH CENTER
CORRECT THE SIERRA CLUB CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY VERY
MUCH POSES- THIS PERMANENT.
EXTENSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I DON'T. I BELIEVE THERE NO ONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. AS A
WITNESS ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE MEMBERS. YES THANK
YOUNG MANAGER- SORRY LITTLE BIT
OUT OF PRACTICE HERE NONE
CALIFORNIA STATE BANK WAS ONE
THE REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT AND I
THOUGHT THAT THEY MIGHT BE ON
THE LINE- BUT THEY OPERATE WITH
SOME OF THE ISSUES WHERE THEY
WERE NOT ABLE TO GET THROUGH SO.
WE JUST IF THEY'RE ALL IN ONE
SPEAKERS SPORT IF NOT I DO WANT
TO REGISTER- CAL FOR SUPPORT OF
THIS PARTICULAR BILL. WE DIDN'T
HAVE THEM LISTED AS A WITNESS
BUT ARE THEY ON THE LINE. ARE
THEY WERE HAVING ISSUES WITH
EVERYTHING ELSE GOING ON SO. THE
PAPER COULD BE PUT OFF THEIR
OPERATOR INEOS OPERATOR ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
ON THE LINE TO SPEAK ON AB FIVE
TWO TWO. IF THERE ARE ANY-
SPEAKERS TO ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK. AT THIS POINT
PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. BUT
EIGHTY ANTI SPECIALIST WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AND WE WILL OPEN UP
THEIR LINES INDIVIDUALLY. WELL
FIRST GO TO LINE- SLICKLINE
FIFTY SIX ONE MOMENT PLEASE. GO
AHEAD PLEASE. A GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
YELLING GAP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS
REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
THERE WAS SOME TECHNICAL ISSUE
SO THAT THE DELAYED SUPPORT BUT
IT'S SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO WE WILL MOVE ON TO ANY
ADDITIONAL. SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR THIS BILL PLEASE
JUST STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
AND WHETHER YOU'RE SUPPORTING OR
OPPOSING THIS BILL. WE WILL MOVE
NEXT TO LINE FIFTY GO AHEAD
PLEASE. YES I HEARING TAYLOR FOR
THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. LINE FORTY SEVEN. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BRIAN WHITE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE FOREST LANDOWNERS
OF CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS BY RICHARD BILL GATES ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES REPORT
THANK YOU. LINE TEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHRIS ROSE- ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH FORESTS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO OTHER
LINES INTO AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU OPERATOR ANY QUESTIONS ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MISTER WHAT. YES A
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR- IS THIS
A BIT IT WAS A WAS MENTIONED BY
ONE WITNESSES THIS IS PERMANENT
NOW IS THAT RIGHT NOT MY READING
OF THIS- THE- IF I CAN ANSWER TO
THE CHAIR OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKEN AS I ACKNOWLEDGE AT
THE BEGINNING EXTENDS THE
EXEMPTION EFFECTIVE DATE TO
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY SIX OKAY
THAT'S SIMPLE I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT CLARIFICATION THANK
YOU. YEAH THAT WAS GOING TO
ADDRESS AND I CLOSE BUT YES YES
THE AUTHOR AGREED. TO THAT
AMENDMENT. ANY OTHER. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. OKAY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES- YOU KNOW JUST
TO- JUST ADDRESS THE OPPOSITION
WHEN YOU APPLY FOR AN EXEMPTION-
THERE THE EXEMPTION STILL
REQUIRE ALL THE FORCE PRACTICE
RULES TO BE MET- IT REQUIRES A
NOTICE FILED WITH THE DEPARTMENT
THAT REQUIRES AN INSPECTION- THE
EXEMPTION IS LIMITED TO
HARVESTING THOSE TREES THAT
ELIMINATE THE VERTICAL
CONTINUITY HAVE IT SHOULD HAVE
FUELS AND HORIZONTAL CONTINUITY
OF TREE GROUNDS FOR REDUCING THE
RATE OF FIRE SPREAD TO RACIAL
INTENSITY- THEY CAN IGNITION OF.
A TREE CROWNS THE EXEMPTION
CONTAINS SPECIFIC PROTECTIONS
FOR WATER COURSES- THE REMAINING
TREES DANCE IMITATIONS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF TEMPORARY ROADS
AND REQUIRES A REGISTERED
PROFESSIONAL FORESTER TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR SUBMITTING THE
NOTICE OF EXEMPTION- EXECUTIVES
OF THE PROJECT REQUIRED TO
MAINTAIN 60% OF FORCE CANOPIES
INCREASE THE AVERAGE STAND
AMMETER- THE LIMITS AND THE
LIMITS ON ROAD CONSTRUCTION ARE
DESIGNED TO PROTECT WATERSHEDS
SO THERE ARE CLEARLY PROTECTIONS
EXISTED AND OF COURSE. AS AS
INDICATED WITH THE AMENDMENTS
AGAIN THESE ARE LOW LIMIT THESE
EXEMPTIONS ARE LIMITED TO THREE
OR ACRES OR LESS SO- THIS IS TO
ENSURE SOME STABILITY AND
CONTINUITY SO THAT- PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS WHO CURRENTLY ACTIVE
MANAGE TO EARN FIFTY THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES
ALREADY SO WE NEED TO ENCOURAGE.
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS TO DO MORE-
THEY ARE A VITAL STAKEHOLDER IN
AND OUR ABILITY TO MAINTAIN OUR
FORCES LANDS. SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR ABOUT. THANK YOU. SO WE
HAVE A MODE. FROM MR FLORES
SECONDED BY MR MATHIS THE
MOTION. IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. I'M SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. RIVAS I
RIVAS I FLOOR FLOOR I BENNETT.
GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE MATHIS-
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
AYE MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI AYE
RADIUS AYEREYES ICY ARCTIC.
STONE STONE NO WOULD WHAT I. THE
BILL HAS EIGHT BUT WE'LL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THIS YEAR-
OKAY SO NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ITEM FOR. AB FIFTEEN NINETEEN BY
MR GALLAGHER. THE. MOVE WILL.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS PRESHEAF YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS BILL TODAY AB
FIFTEEN NINETEEN- AS YOU KNOW-
WE'VE REALLY BEEN WORKING ON
THIS WILDFIRE. ISSUE IN
PREVENTION- AND SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING IN THE BUDGET. LAST YEAR
THAT WILL GO INTO DOING THE MUCH
NEEDED ACTIVITIES INCLUDING
SENDING- MECHANICAL. FORESTRY
MANAGEMENT- PRESCRIBED FIRE MANY
DIFFERENT METHODS TO ENSURE THAT
WE GET OUR FORCE INTO A
HEALTHIER CAN CONDITION GET A
LOT OF THE BRUSH AND FUEL LOADS-
THAT MAKE OUR- FORCE A TINDER
BOX WAITING TO HAPPEN. AND HELP
AVOID- DEVASTATING FIRES LIKE IN
PARADISE LIKE IN GREENVILLE.
LIKE IN BERRY CREEK- IN MY PART
OF THE STATE- BUT THE ONE THE
ONE BIG THING THAT WE HAVE BEEN
MISSING- AND THAT IS A VERY MUCH
A PART OF THIS PICTURE IS
BIOMASS AND REALLY INCENTIVIZING
BIOMASS PLANTS- BECAUSE YOU CAN
YOU CAN GET IN THERE AND DO THE
WORK OF. REMOVING THE BRUSH AND
THE- AND THE DEAD AND DYING
TREES BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
PLACE TO TAKE IT. AND THE
REALITY IS NOW WE HAVE WE DO NOT
HAVE THE CAPACITY. TO TAKE THAT
WOULD YOU WASTE AND DO SOMETHING
WITH IT THAT IS MUCH BETTER THAN
WHAT THE ALTERNATIVES ARE RIGHT
NOW- WE HAD SIXTY SIX BIOMASS
PLANTS- AT. SO WE'VE LOST IT TWO
THIRDS OF THAT CAPACITY TO TAKE
THIS ON SO WHAT FIFTEEN NINETEEN
DOES IT PROVIDES AN INCENTIVE.
TO HELP ENSURE THAT WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE BIOMASS FACILITIES THAT
CAN TAKE IN THIS WAY IS THE
BIGGEST COST DRIVER AND HERE'S
HOW IT WORKS RIGHT NOW A LOT OF
TIMES BY MASS. IS OPERATING TO
PRODUCE ELECTRICITY- BUT THEY
ONLY GET PAID SO MUCH FOR THAT
ELECTRICITY PRODUCED IT'S NOT
ENOUGH TO COVER THE COSTS. AND
ONE OF THE BIGGEST COST DRIVERS
IS TRANSPORTATION IT'S GETTING.
YOU KNOW THE- THIS WOULD BE WAYS
FROM THE FORCE VERY REMOTE
AREAS- TO THE BIOMASS PLANTS. I
LOOK I WANT TO WORK ON US
GETTING MANY OF THESE BIOMASS
PLANTS IN THESE AREAS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES AND THAT'S ALSO PART
OF THIS BECAUSE THIS COULD HELP
INCENTIVIZE THAT- BUT WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE INCENTIVIZING
AGAIN AND- RATING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE THESE
BIOMASS PLANTS. TO BE CREATED-
AND HERE'S THE ALTERNATIVE AND
THIS IS THE REALITY THAT WE'RE
FACING RIGHT NOW IS IF WE ARE
NOT TAKING THIS WOULD BE WASTE.
TO BIOMASS FACILITIES IS EITHER
GOING TO BE OPEN BURNED IN A IN
A FIRE WHICH IS THE WORST
ALTERNATIVE AND LAST YEAR ALONE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION METRIC TONS
OF CARBON- WERE EMITTED INTO OUR
ATMOSPHERE BY DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES IT KEEPS GETTING APPAN
ACTUALLY BIGGER- FOR THEY'RE
JUST GONNA BE LEFT AS A BRUSH
PILE SOMEWHERE ON SOME PROPERTY-
A RECENT. STUDY HAS SHOWN THAT
AS COMPARED TO THOSE
ALTERNATIVES- BIOMASS A FACTUAL
ENSURES THAT AT BIOMASS ENERGY
GENERATION RESULTS IN NINETY
EIGHT TO NINETY PERCENT. 99%
LOWER PM TWO FIVE- THAT CARBON
MONOXIDE METHANE AND BLACK
CARBON EMISSIONS COMPARED TO
OPEN PILE BURNING. WILL BE DOING
A SUBSTANTIAL THING FOR THE
CLIMATE BY ENSURING THAT WE HAVE
THESE BIOMASS FACILITIES- IN
PLACE NOW I'VE- AND THIS IS
WHERE I WANT TO TALK TO MY
FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS IS I
REALLY THINK WE CAN GET
SOMEWHERE ON THIS BILL. AND I AM
COMMITTED TO TAKING AMENDMENTS
THAT ADDRESS THE TWO PRIMARY
ISSUES BROUGHT UP IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. ONE WAS THAT
THESE WOULD NOT BE.
INCENTIVIZING BIOMASS IN AREAS
WHERE WE HAVE NON ATTAINMENT I'M
I'M AGREEABLE TO TAKEN THAT
AMOUNT- AND A LOT OF THESE AREAS
WERE WERE TRYING TO GET MORE
BIOMASS. MOST OF MY DISTRICT IS
ENTERTAINMENT RIGHT NOW- MANY OF
THE AREAS WHERE WE NEED TO BRING
ON NEW BIOMASS PLANTS THERE IN.
ATTAINMENT AFTER THEY'RE A
QUALITY GOALS. SO I'M GOING TO
TAKE AMENDMENTS YOU KNOW TO
ENSURE THEY DON'T GO TO NON
ATTAINMENT AREAS UNLESS THE
LOCAL AIRBOARD. WITH THEIR OWN
PLAN AND PROJECT IS AMENABLE TO
IT- AND THEN THE SECOND ONE IS
WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE THOSE THAT
ALREADY HAVE THE NINE OH ONE
CONTRACTS. AND ALREADY GETTING
SOME INCENTIVE FROM THAT TO GET
IT. TO GET THIS INCENTIVE I'M
FINE WITH TAKING NOT AMENDMENT-
SO LONG AS THEY COULD APPLY FOR
ONCE THEIR CONTRACT IS UP- AND
SO THAT YOU KNOW ONCE THAT
CONTRACT IS OVER THEN THEY
COULD. THEN UTILIZE IT BUT THIS
IS REALLY FOCUSED ON THOSE THAT
DON'T HAVE NINE OH ONE
CONTRACTS. THAT ARE ENTERTAINED
AIR ATTAINMENT AREAS AND TO
INCENTIVIZE THE NEW BECAUSE WE
NEED MORE CAPACITY WE NEED MORE
PLANTS. AND THE BIGGEST THING
THAT'S GOING TO HELP BRING THOSE
COME ONLINE. WE'VE DONE THIS FOR
SOLAR WE SUBSIDIZE SOLAR AND NOW
WE HAVE A BURGEONING SOLAR
INDUSTRY IN THE STATE. WE
SUBSIDIZE WIND NOW WE HAVE A
BURGEONING STE WIND ENERGY. IN
THE STATE. THIS IS A KEY STEP TO
THE COULD REALLY GROW BY A
MASTER'S NEW TECHNOLOGIES COMING
ON EVERY DAY IN THIS FIELD- TALK
WITH PEOPLE UC BERKELEY AND
OTHER INSTITUTES- THEY'RE COMING
UP WITH TECHNOLOGY WHERE WILL BE
ZERO EMISSION- BIOMASS. BIOMASS
PRODUCTION THAT COULD CREATE
HYDROGEN. THE CLEAN HYDROGEN
THAT WE CAN USE. IN OTHER
CAPACITIES OF THIS IS REALLY THE
KEY. WE'VE GOT A CRACK THIS NUT
IF YOU REALLY WANT TO GET OUT
THE PROBLEM. AND ASK FOR YOUR
HELP WITH THIS AGAIN I'M WILLING
TO TAKE THOSE AMENDMENTS- TO
ADDRESS THE MAJOR CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN ADDRESSING THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. AND I HOPE
THAT I CAN GET YOUR SUPPORT-
FROM MOVING THIS FOR TODAY.
THANK YOU. I DO HAVE. SOME
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE- ONE IS
SUPERVISOR DOUG TEETER. WHO DOES
A FANTASTIC JOB REPRESENTING BE
COUNTY BUT IS ALSO A- PARADISE
CAN'T FIRE SURVIVOR- AND DOES
THIS ISSUE WELL AND JOHN
KENNEDY- WITH RC RC. THANK YOU
HI WE ARE READY FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OPERATOR. CAN YOU PLEASE
. WHAT THE WITNESSES ON THEIR
WITNESSES. ALL THOSE ARE MISTER
PETERS LINE IS OPEN THOSE OF
THOSE WHOSE LINE YOUR WITNESSES
ARE ALREADY OPEN. ARE YOU
CALLING FOR THE PUBLIC AT THIS
POINT. NO I'M DOUG SUPERVISOR
DOUG TEETER. I'M HERE IF YOU CAN
HEAR ME YES WE CAN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY THANK YOU- I CAN'T
WAIT TELL US ALL THESE CO HIT
THE ISSUES ARE BEHIND US-
HOPEFULLY SOON- YES I'D LIKE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THAT JAMES
GALLAGHER- HAS MENTIONED- BUTTE
COUNTY SUPERVISOR I'M ALSO ON
OUR FIRE SAFE COUNCILS A BOARD
MEMBER. AND A PARADISE RESIDENT
UP CURRENTLY- A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE JUST- BURNING FUELS- THAT.
BUT THE ARMS OF THE CAMPFIRE ON
THEIR PROPERTY- PRETTY EXPENSIVE
TO- GET THINGS AN HOUR AND A
HALF TO GO TO WHEELABRATOR- TO
PUT IT IN A PILE BASS SO- ADS
FOR YOUR YES VOTE AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT READY
FOR JOHN KENNEDY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME'S JOHN KENNEDY AND I'M
WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA RC
RC IS COMPRISED OF THIRTY EIGHT
WORLD COUNTIES AND WE'RE PLEASED
TO SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN NINETEEN
TODAY. OUR MEMBER COUNTIES OF
REALLY SUFFERED A LOT OF THE
STATE'S MOST CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES OVER THE LAST DECADE
AND WE AGREE WITH- THE AUTHORS
NOTE ABOUT GHG EMISSIONS FROM
WILDFIRES- FOUR MILLION ACRES
AND NINETY MILLION MTRIC TONS
OF EMISSIONS IN TWENTY TWENTY
THAT'S MORE THAN ALL THE
EMISSIONS FROM INDUSTRIAL
SOURCES ANNOUNCED ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WILDFIRE RISK
REDUCTION IN FUEL MANAGEMENT IS
SO IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE'S
OBJECTIVES. SO WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL BECAUSE WE
THINK IT'LL HELP IMPROVE
COMMUNITY WILDFIRE PROTECTION
REMOVED FUEL PILES FROM THE
FOREST AND IMPORTANTLY REDUCE
LOCAL AIR QUALITY IMPACT IN
PARTICULAR TAKES TO PROVIDE A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO HELP GET
SOME OF THE MATERIAL- THAT WOULD
BE TO GRANTS PASS OUT OF THE
FORCE TO THE TIME OUT THE SOUL
IS. SO I WON'T GO BACK ON WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THE MATERIAL-
WITHOUT PARAMOUNT'S DISABILITIES
BECAUSE IT'S LEFT TO BURN OR TO-
DEGRADE NATURALLY AND THAT GIVES
OFF OFF A LOT OF EMISSIONS THAT-
THE RECENT STUDY REFERENCED BY
POTTER COUNTY OR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT UC BERKELEY UC
DAVIS THE US FOREST SERVICE
SHOWN A REDUCED SIGNIFICANTLY
98299% BY BIOMASS. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THERE ARE MANY MORE SMALLER
BY ABOUT THE FILTERS THAT ARE
COMING ONLINE AND A LOT OF THE
RURAL AREAS- AND THESE
FACILITIES OFTENTIMES DO HAVE
SOME BETTER EMISSIONS CONTROL
DEVICES- AND WE THINK THIS WOULD
BE IMPORTANT FOR THAT YOU KNOW
ALSO ON. THE COMMISSION HOUSES
RIGHT UP THE BY RAMMING THE BIO
MAT PROGRAMS THAT LEVERAGE BY
MATHIS SALAS REPETITIVE MANAGED
FIFTEEN NINETEEN DIFFERENT AND
IMPORTANT RESPECTS BECAUSE THE
FACILITIES THAT PARTICIPATE IN
THOSE PROGRAMS. ARE FOR ON
PEOPLE'S COULDN'T PROVIDE THEM.
EIGHT FIFTEEN. FOCUS ON
MATERIALS THAT FARTHER AWAY FROM
THE TO SELL. AND BY PHONE INTO
ON BY. LOCATED MILES PER MILES
OR MORE FROM FACILITY. THE WILL
HELP MORE CAN UNDER FUEL
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS THAT THEY
NEED UNDER TO SERVE. AND REDUCE
THE ERA IS. WITH THOSE PROJECTS
. WE THINK THE AMENDMENTS
OFFERED. BY THE AUTHOR TO STRIKE
A NICE BALANCE UNDER ARE SIMILAR
IN SCOPE TO WHAT WAS- IN AB
THREE FORTY THREE BY SESSION- BY
MR PATTERSON. AND STRONGLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY ON FIFTEEN
NINETEEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE. THANK YOU NEXT
ALREADY FOR WITNESSES IN%
OPPOSITION- WE HAVE DANIEL BROAD
FROM THE SIERRA CLUB. AND BRIAN
NO WIKI FROM THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY. GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN DANIEL BROUGHT
ON BEHALF OF THEIR CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION AB
FIFTEEN CAN. THE BILL WOULD USE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND TO
PROVIDE GRANTS FOR TREES TO BE
TRANSPORTED FROM THE FORESTS TO
POLLUTING BIOMASS GENERATORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA'S GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND IS INTENDED TO
SUBSIDIZE PROGRAMS THAT REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AND
ACHIEVE CO BENEFITS AND
COMMUNITY AT THE UPPER AIR
QUALITY IMPACTS OF DIRTY ENERGY
. AB FIFTEEN NINETEEN UNDER
MONTHS BOTH OF THESE CALLS USING
STATE FUNDS TO TRANSPORT BIOMASS
WITH POLLUTING DIESEL TRUCKS. TO
COMMUNITY IS FOR IN CALIFORNIA'S
MOST POLLUTING AIR AND WHERE THE
BIOMASS PLANT WILL CONTRIBUTE TO
LOCAL AIR POLLUTION AND MAKE
SOME OF THE STATE'S STURDIEST
AND MOST EXPENSIVE ENERGY. ALL
OF THIS IS A CLEAR AND THAT NAY.
SO THE CLIMATE AND- CALIFORNIA'S
BIG BIOMASS GENERATORS AND A AND
I'M AT LARGE AMOUNTS OF FINE
PROTECT MATTER. AND THAT NIGHT
TRAP AND OXIDE OF NITROGEN WHICH
IS A PRECURSOR. CALIFORNIA IS
AIMING TO REDUCE ITS GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS CLEAN IT THERE AND
REDUCE ITS VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED PARTICULARLY MILES
TRAVELED BY DIESEL TRUCKS.
FUNDING TRANSPORTATION OF CARBON
BY A DIESEL TRUCK FROM
CALIFORNIA'S FOR IT TO BE AND
GENERATED AND THIRTY FOOT BUT
IT. AND SOME OF THEM THAT AND IN
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN THE
MOST OVERBURDENED BY AIR
POLLUTION. IS IN DIRECT. TO
CALIFORNIA'S VALUES AND FEDERAL
AIR QUALITY APPLICATION. AND
THEY'RE CUT CALIFORNIA OPPOSES
AB FIFTEEN NINETEEN AND ASKED
ABOUT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
NEXT BRIAN A WIKI. YES A GOOD
AFTERNOON BRIAN A WIKI CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- THE
WHOLE ORGANIC KNOWLEDGE THAT THE
BILL ANALYSIS BY THE COMMITTEE
REALLY DID. REALLY DID POINT OUT
SOME OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS
WITH THIS BILL AND I AND I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES-
EFFORTS TO OFFICER AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THOSE AND THOSE ARE.
THOSE ARE SMART WAYS OF TRYING
TO REDUCE SOME OF THE BIGGEST
NEGATIVE AFFECTS OF THIS BILL-
THAT SAID. IS IT AS MENTIONED
OFTEN ENOUGH THIS AND I THINK IT
KNOWLEDGE OF PARENTS WE TALK
ABOUT THE WERE ALREADY PAYING
BOTTOM THE BANK TWO AND A HALF
TIME AS MUCH IT REQUIRING
REPAIRS TO BE TWO AND A HALF
TIMES AS MUCH FOR ENERGY COMING
FROM BIOMASS AS THEY ARE FROM
OTHER ENERGY SOURCES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT IS WE ARE YOU
DUMPING A LOT OF MONEY. INTO
BIOMASS AND PROPPING IT UP- WITH
A LOT OF REPAIR MONEY TO THROW
THIS TAXPAYER MONEY IN ON TOP OF
IT TAKING IT AWAY FROM
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION EFFORTS
AND PUTTING IT INTO BIOMASS
SPECIFICALLY AND EVEN WORSE INTO
TRANSPORTING BY DIESEL TO THOSE
BIOMASS FACILITIES AT
POTENTIALLY AT LONG DISTANCES IS
PROBABLY. NOT HELPING THE
PROBLEM SO ANY OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE HEAR TOGETHER ARE TRYING
TO SOLVE- AND THEN THE LAST
THING TO SAY IS THAT- LONG
DISTANCE TRANSPORT OF THE FUELS
THERE'S MANY PROBLEMS WITH
FINANCE AND MANY OF THEM ARE
MADE MORE DIFFICULT WHEN YOU SAY
WE'RE GOING TO INCREASE THE
DISTANCES THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
MOVE THIS BOTTOM AROUND THE.
THANK YOU VERY. THE CENTER FOR
ABOUT DIVERSITY. IN OPPOSITION
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M NEXT WILL. WITH AND OVERSEAS
OPEN UP TO WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
AND OR ALL PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THIS BILL GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
MAKAYLA ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANY'S IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
NINETEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM OPERATOR
CAN YOU OPEN THE LINES TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB. FIFTEEN
NINETEEN. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF FIFTEEN
OF AB FIFTY NINETEEN PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WELL
FIRST GO TO LINE FIFTY ONE- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS- RICHARD
STILL GETS ON BEHALF OF THE
SITUATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WILL MOVE ON TO LINE TEN. GO
AHEAD PLEASE ON BEHALF CHRIS
ROSA ON BEHALF OF KELP FORESTS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. IN MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THE TOP. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MISTER MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR GALLAGHER FIRST I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR
TIRELESS EFFORTS TO FIGHT FOR
YOUR COMMUNITIES LIKE I KNOW
THAT I'M JUST ONE OF MANY.
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE- WHO
FOLLOW YOUR LEAD IN THE TOUR OF
PARADISE AFTER- THE FIRE THERE
AND- AND I KNOW THAT WE'VE HAD
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT TO. THE
URGENCY OF- FIGHTING WILDFIRES
THROUGH FORCE MANAGEMENT-
PRESCRIBED BURNS THINNING AND
ALL OTHER TOOLS THAT WE HAVE.
ARE AVAILABLE TO US. ARM WHICH
IS THE REASON WHY. YOU KNOW I
MEAN START COMPARE YOUR BILL TO
THE PREVIOUS BILL YOUR YOUR-
BILL WITH MR FONG BUT NORMALLY I
DON'T VOTE. YOU KNOW A FOR BILL.
THE SIERRA CLUB IN THE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY POSES-
BUT I VOTED FOR MR FONG A BILL.
BUT I AM HAVING PROBLEMS WITH
WITH YOUR BILL- I MEAN IT'S JUST
THE PRINCIPAL ON THE CONCEPT AS
OF SPENDING. G. R. F. FUNDS THAT
WERE DESIGNED TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS. YOU KNOW FOR A-
DIESEL TRUCKS. ASIA YOU KNOW-
THE TRANSPORTING CARE. VIA THE
WHAT PRODUCTS. THAT HAVE BEEN
CUT DOWN AS PART OF THE FOR THE
FOR STANDING. YOU KNOW IT IT
JUST. I WANT TO. YOU KNOW I KNOW
THAT I MAY NOT SHARE THE SAME
PASSION AND LEVEL OF COMMITMENT
TO FIGHTING WILDFIRES AS AS YOU
TO BE GIVEN THE COMMUNITIES THAT
YOU REPRESENT BUT THE THIS BILL
I MEAN UNLESS THE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT AN AMENDMENT WORDS EUROPE
BILLS- FUNDS ARE NOT GOING TO
HELP OUT WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION- YOU KNOW I DON'T
THINK I CAN GET THERE BUT- WANT
TO SEE IF HE HAD IN RESPONSE TO
THAT. YEAH I APPRECIATE THAT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- AND THANK YOU
FOR. YOUR ATTENTION AND THAT MAN
FOR COMING UP AND SEEN- YOU KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE CAMPFIRE
AND YOU HAVE BEEN YOU KNOW
SUPPORT OF THE EFFORTS TO REALLY
HELP US. IN THAT RESPECT SO AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE I THINK THE
THING THAT I WOULD. HAVE YOU
THINK ABOUT. IT IN RESPONSE TO
YOUR CONCERN. IS THAT IF WE
DON'T SUBSIDIZE THIS AND HAVE
THIS GO INTO A BIOMASS FACILITY
- THAT- BROSH DEAD AND DYING
TREES THAT WE THAT WE CUT DOWN
AND THEN NOW IT HAS NOWHERE TO
GO WHICH MEANS IT WILL EITHER
JUST BE LEFT THERE ON THE FOURTH
FLOOR. OR IT WILL BE. SENT TO A
PLACE WHERE THEY OPEN BURN IT.
IN WHICH CASE IN EITHER CASE
THAT'S A MUCH WORSE RESULTS. FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT- BECAUSE ONCE
THAT'S BURNED YOU KNOW THIS THE
STUDY THAT IT WAS REFERENCE UC
BERKELEY UC DAVIS. HAS SAID
THAT'S YOU KNOW 9899% MORE PM
THAT'S GOING INTO THE AIR- IT'S
GOING INTO THE AIR SO- I THINK
WE ALL AGREE WE GOT TO GET THAT
STUFF OUT OF THE FORCE CAUSES IT
MAKES IT. SO MUCH MORE FIRE
PRONE BUT OUR PROBLEM IS YOU
GOTTA GET IT SOMEWHERE TO WHERE
IT'S GOING TO BE DISPOSED OF
AND- IN THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE
AND THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW IS BIOMASS NOW.
THE TECHNOLOGY IS GETTING BETTER
TOO I MEAN THE TECHNOLOGY CAN
BETTER WHERE WE CAN ALTERNATELY
HAVE PLANTS COME ONLINE THAT
HAVE THAT ARE ZEROING BETTERS-
AND SO. I THINK IT IS JUST LIKE
WITH MANY THINGS WE'VE DONE
LET'S MAKE THE INVESTMENT LET'S
MAKE THE INVESTMENT NOW SO THAT
WE'RE GOING TO ENSURE THAT THIS
HAS A MUCH BETTER PLACE TO GO
THAN THAN THE ALTERNATIVE WHICH
I THINK WE ALL CAN AGREE IS NOT
GOOD FOR THE ENVIRONMENT. IF I
MAY IF I MAY FOLLOW UP THE GO
AHEAD. SO MR GALLAGHER I- I DID
PARTICIPATE IN THERE ARE SEVERAL
TOURS OF THE NORTH STATE- BOTH
IN YOUR DISTRICT AS WELL AS AND
MISSED WAS- DISTRICT- AND I DID
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO TOUR A
BIOMASS FACILITY WITH- THE
STRINGENT EMISSION CONTROL
TECHNOLOGY THAT THAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING ARM I AM JUST
WONDERING GUY I HEARD IN TODAY'S
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE- MONIES
TO EXPLORE- EXPANDING WHAT
PRODUCT MARKETS I KNOW THAT- IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN AS REFERENCED IN
THE BILL ANALYSIS- IN THERE
THERE WAS A- WORKING GROUP
ESTABLISHED ON EXPANDING WOULD
PRODUCT MARKETS AND THERE WAS
ALSO A BILL- BY. OUR COLLEAGUE
MS AGUIAR-CURRY AYE AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- IT TOO TO FURTHER
EXPLORE IT- THESE OTHER FORCE
PRODUCTS WHY ARE THESE- WOOD
PRODUCT MARKETS- YEAH EIGHT
INADEQUATE. TO- YOU KNOW AVOID
THE ALTERNATIVE THAT I AGREE IS
NOT TO ENVIRONMENTALLY- FRIENDLY
THEY THE OPEN PILE BURNING- IT'S
PART OF IT I MEAN THAT'S
DEFINITELY PART OF IT IS THAT
MARKET- AND I THINK THAT'S
HELPFUL I MEAN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ACTUALLY ALSO OUTLINES- I
BELIEVE IT'S TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR TRANSPORTATION- SO THAT'S IN
LINE WITH WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT YOUR TRANSPORTATION OF
WOODY. BIOMASS FUELS- SO THIS
WOULD BE IN LINE WITH NO I
HAVEN'T SEEN THE DETAILS OF WHAT
THAT IS YET DEFINITELY WANT TO.
WORK ON THAT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT BUT I THINK WHAT I'M SAYING
IS I THINK IT DOVETAILS AND
REALLY NICELY WITH WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE. THERE IS THE MARKET
PLACE- FOR OTHER WHAT WHAT
PRODUCTS THEY CAN BE THEY CAN BE
GENERATED FROM. THIS BOMB ****
BUT THE PROBLEM IS JUST PAT THE
REAL PROBLEM IS JUST CAPACITY TO
TAKE OUT THIS AMOUNT TO DO FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES A YEAR
WHICH IS OUR GOAL. YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF WOODY
BIOMASS THAT YOU'RE GONNA NEED
TO DO SOMETHING WITH NO PART OF
IT IS THE MARKET FOR THOSE
PRODUCTS BUT IT'S- BIOMASS IS
GOT TO BE PART OF THAT PICTURE.
TO OUR- MR MCCARTY. THANK YOU
I'M NOT IN SHARE SO MR GALLAGHER
I'M HAVING HAD A TOUGH TIME HERE
AND I RESPECT WHAT YOU'RE COMING
AFTER SAID THAT IF YOU QUESTIONS
ON THIS BUT AS MR MARTUCCI SAID
I'VE I'VE BEEN UP TO MISTER
WOODS JUST CHECK IN MISTER
DOLLARS AND SEEN THIS FIRST HAND
YOU KNOW MY MEMORIES LOW SOUGHT
AFTER MAKEOVER FLOP THIS PAST
SUMMER'S I BLAME MY MEMORY ON
CODE BUT THE TWO THINGS I
REMEMBER FROM THAT STORE ARE.
YOU KNOW THE TIMBER HARVEST
PLANS WHICH YOU TALKED ABOUT A
FEW MINUTES AGO MR FONG SPELL
AND ALL THE WITH THE MATERIAL
LEFT ON THAT THE FOREST FLOOR
AND IT. SPLIT SPEARS- FUELS IN
THOSE FIRES AND I KNOW YOU AND
OTHERS MR WOULD HAVE TALKED.
ABOUT THAT AMOUNT OF. I DAMAGE
TO OUR- ENVIRONMENT IT'S ENOUGH
. PARTICULAR MATTER AND OVERALL
OF THE MISSIONS- BY THESE FIRES
IS JUST OUTRAGEOUS SO I GET
THAT. I'M TRYING TO GRAPPLE WITH
THERE IS I GUESS THIS BILL IS
NOT QUITE WHAT MR PATTERSON WE
TALK ABOUT A FEW YEARS AGO AND
YOU'RE OFFERING A FEW THINGS
HERE. BUT THE BIG PICTURE IS YOU
KNOW YOU AND I SERVED ON THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE TOGETHER AND-
OING IT. THERE'S ALWAYS
PROPOSALS THAT COME FORWARD TO
THE BUDGET AND THROUGH POLICY
AND- YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE LUCKY WE
CAME IN THE SAME YEAR IF YOU
LOOK AT ALL THE BILLS HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED. WHICH TRY TO LATCH
ON. TO TEACH OUR F. MONIES.
WOULD SPEND IT LIKE IN A FIFTEEN
FOLD. AND SO THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
THAT. BUT COMMITTEE WHICH IN
SOME NUMBERS HERE. SERVED ON AND
WE COME UP WITH THAT TDRS
SPENDING PLAN AND. I JUST READ
THE EVERYDAY THAT THE- REVENUES
FROM THE AUCTION ARE. MUCH
HIGHER THAN PROJECTED SO THEY'VE
SHOULD BE OPPORTUNITY THAT-
THERE WAS MONEY LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET SO. WHY DO WE NEED. THIS
BILL. IF IT'S REALLY A BUDGET
ISSUE. AND YOU KNOW WE ARE
SUCCESSFUL YOU WERE SUCCESSFUL
LAST YEAR GETTING MONIES TO
ADDRESS. BIOMASS YEAH NO THAT'S
A GOOD QUESTION- WELL THE MONEY
LAST YEAR WAS NOT FOR BIOMASS IT
WAS FOR FUEL REDUCTION SURE
RIGHT SO JUST GET IN THERE AND
DOING DOING THE WORK BUT TO YOUR
POINT THAT'S WHERE I THINK THIS
THIS IS ACTUALLY HAS SYNERGY
WITH THE BUDGET RIGHT BECAUSE
GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED TODAY THAT HE
IS ACTUALLY ALLOCATING MONIES
TOWARDS TREND TOWARDS
TRANSPORTATION COSTS FOR WHAT HE
FEELS- SO- LET'S ARE THERE I'M I
HAVEN'T SEEN EXACTLY WHAT HE IS
SAYING IT WHERE THAT FUND WOULD
COME FROM- BUT IT WOULD MAKE
SENSE TO COME FROM GIGI R. F.
BECAUSE- NO ONE. WE'VE ALREADY
MADE A COMMITMENT FROM GIGI R.
F. FOR FUEL REDUCTION. RIGHT NOW
WE'VE COMMITTED TO FIVE YEARS
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION FROM
GIGI R. F. TO GO IN AND DO. A
FEW MORE DUTCH ALREADY. THANK.
THE NEW- SO WE'VE ALREADY TO
SPENDING DID YOU OF MONE TO
REMOVE THE FUEL THIS IS ABOUT
HOW YOU GET IT TO A PLACE WHERE
IT CAN BE DISPOSED OF IN THE
MOST ENVIRONMENTALLY. BESSEMER
EMILY FROM THE WAY WE HAVE AT
THIS TIME AND AGAIN THE
TECHNOLOGY IS GETTING BETTER SO-
TO ME LIKE THIS. IF YOU JUST
LEAVE IT OUT THERE. OR IF YOU
LEAVE IT. PILED UP SOMEWHERE.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A CARBON
EMITTER OF MUCH GREATER
PROPORTION THAN IF YOU. BURN
THIS IN A BIOMASS FACILITY WHERE
YOU HAVE AT LEAST. YOU KNOW SOME
CONTROL OVER THAT AND CONTROL
OVER EMISSIONS I GET THAT BUT- I
KNOW LOOKING BACK TO PRIOR NOT
TO RESOURCES SHARES. CRISTINA
GARCIA MURATSUCHI INVESTMENT. IN
MY YEARS HERE WE'VE HAD TONS OF
G. DIRECT BILLS SO WE KIND OF
TABLE THEM- BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
THAT'S PRECLUDED THERE'S A
BUDGET PROCESS OF. SHOULDN'T YOU
AND- THEN OMEONE WERE TALI AND
SUMMER WOULD FOCUS ON YOU KNOW
BUDGET ASKED TO FOCUS ON HOW THE
NORTH STATE HE COULD ADDRESS
THIS IN. R. G. G. R. AFTER.
SPENDING PLAN AS OPPOSED TO.
PREDETERMINE AND CIRCUMVENT THAT
BUDGET PROCESS HERE IN UP
THROUGH THESE POLICY BILLS. YEAH
WELL I'M NOT I'M NOT
PREDETERMINED THIS IS THE POLICY
PART RIGHT WE'RE SORRY IN THE
POLICY IN PLACE. THAT DIRECTS
THE- YOU KNOW DEPARTMENT OF
NATURAL RESOURCES TO HAVE A
GRANT PROGRAM. RIGHT THAT'S
GONNA HAVE TO BE FUNDED. AND
THAT'S THE BUDGETARY ISSUES SO.
YEP I THINK WE DO THAT ALL OF
FRONT RIGHT I MEAN- IN EDUCATION
SET THE POLICY BUT THEN WE'RE ON
THE EDUCATION SUB OR WE GO OKAY
HOW DO WE FUND. THAT POLICY THAT
WE'VE THAT WE'VE SET FOR LIKE
FOR INSTANCE CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION- SO I THINK THERE IS
SYNERGIES HERE BETWEEN BOTH OF
THOSE. AND THAT'S WE WANT TO FIT
TOGETHER- AND I WOULD NOTE THAT
ACTUALLY NATURAL RESOURCES DID
PASS OUT. A VERY SIMILAR BILL TO
THIS I DON'T POINT OUT- JIM
PATTERSON IS MY CO AUTHOR IT WAS
HIS LEGISLATION- LAST- LAST
TERM- THE PASTOR NATURI SOURCES
WITH SOME SIMILAR AMENDMENTS
THAT. WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING
TODAY. THANK YOU. HOW MISTER
MATHIS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
JUST WANNA THANK YOU ARE CALLING
MR GALLAGHER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IN ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE
ON ON THE POLICY SIDE AND- YOU
KNOW IT'S FASCINATING BECAUSE WE
ALWAYS HEAR ABOUT THIS- WE DON'T
WANT TO PAY TO HAVE DIESEL
TRUCKS ALMOST OF DALIT THE FACT
OF IT IS. DUE TO PROGRAMS THAT
WE DID IN CAP AND TRADE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A- REAL BOSSED.
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS THAT'S
COMING OFF OF DAIRIES NOW. AND
THAT'S ACTUALLY FEELING THESE
TRUCKS AND A LOT AREAS. SO
YOU'RE YOU'RE ACTUALLY USING.
SOME OF THESE MODELS THAT WE
BUILT OUT AND OTHER SIDES OF
GREENHOUSE GAS AND OF CAP AND
TRADE ON WITH THESE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT CAN NOW ACTUALLY
HOLD THIS STUFF SO TO SAY THAT
IT'S- ONLY DIESEL FUELS. IS
INCORRECT. WE HAVE OTHER. HEAVY
EQUIPMENT TRUCKS THAT ARE
RUNNING OFF OF RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS. SO THEY ANY GETS PAST TIME
WE STOP USING THE ARGUMENT OF
IT'S ONLY BEING HAULED BY DIESEL
BECAUSE OF INCORRECT- THIS HAS
TO GET DONE. EVERY YEAR YOU KNOW
MY DISTRICT WE WERE HAVE IN
FOREST FIRES AND IT WAS RAINING
ASHES ON US BEFORE IT WAS SEXY
AND HAPPEN TO OTHER PEOPLE IN
OTHER AREAS. THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENS EVERY YEAR. CLICK
INTEL WE ACTUALLY GO IN AND DO
WITH THIS BILL INTENDS TO DO AND
GET THIS WASTE OUT. OF OUR
FOREST. IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE
TO HAPPEN WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
TO HAVE AIR QUALITY SHOULD WE'RE
GONNA THE THESE THINGS ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO HAPPEN SO THEN
WE'RE GONNA HAVE INCREASED COSTS
ON THE HEALTHCARE- SIDE. AND
EVERYWHERE ELSE. WE'VE SEEN IT.
SO SIT HERE AND ARE YOU IS THIS
THE RIGHT PLACE TO DO IT SHOULD
BE A BUDGET ASK FOR SHOULD WE DO
THIS WE DO THIS OF ALL TIME. ON
THE WATERFRONT. I KNOW HOW MANY
BILLS WE HAVE ALL PASSED IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS. THEY DO GREAT
PROGRAMS TO HELP WITH WATER
QUALITY ISSUES. BUT THEN ON THE
BUDGET SIDE WE TURN AROUND AND
ALL MONIES ARE PUT INTO THE
PROGRAMS. SO THAT PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT DON'T HAVE GOOD QUALITY
WATER. BECAUSE IT DOESN'T FUND.
THIS IS A POLICY BILL. THAT
CLEANS UP THE AIR QUALITY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE
PROVEN STUDIES FROM MULTIPLE
LABS. THAT SHOW. THIS IS A
BETTER WAY TO DISPOSE OF THE
MATERIAL THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT HUMAN IT TOOK TO BURNING
RAIN ASHES ON YOUR CONSTITUENTS
PRETTY WANNA DISPOSE OF IT IN
THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE. I MOVE
THAT WE DISPOSE OF IT IN THE
BEST WAY POSSIBLE MISTER GALLERY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR BILL. MISTER
WHAT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
JUST A JUST A FEW COMMENTS- I
DON'T KNOW. I DON'T KNOW HOW
CLOSE. WHAT THE AUTHOR IS
OFFERING GETS YOU TO WHERE THE
PREVIOUS BILL WAS- COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO I DON'T MY MEMORY
ISN'T THAT GOOD. SO WHAT THAT'LL
LOOK LIKE BUT BUT I THINK IS A
KEY THING THERE THAT THAT'S
MEANT WAS MENTIONED AND THAT
HE'S HE'S ASKING FOR THIS TO NOT
BE ALLOWED IN IN NON ATTAINMENT
AREAS SO- I THINK THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT LOOK I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS.
RESISTANCE TO BIOMASS IN SOME
AREAS BECAUSE OF HOW IT'S DONE-
BUT I LIVE IN ONE OF THOSE AREAS
THAT IS AN ATTAINMENT AND- YOU
KNOW WE'VE BERMAN WE'VE LOST A
COUPLE MILLION ACRES IN THE LAST
THREE OR FOUR YEARS- WENT WHEN
THOSE FIRES HAPPEN. THE FIRES
HAPPENED- ALL THE FOLKS TO THE
SOUTH OF US AND IN SACRAMENTO
COMPLAIN ABOUT THE AIR QUALITY-
THE THAT THEY GET THE BRIEF- I
WISH THEY MIGHT COME AND VISIT
US DURING SOME OF THESE FIRES
AND EXPERIENCE. WHAT IT'S LIKE
ON THE GROUND TO BITS OF DEBRIS
THAT AIR QUALITY- AND- AND
RECOGNIZE THAT. IF WE CONTINUE
DOWN THE PATH WE'RE GOING. ON
THAT'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER
YEAR. SO HERE WE ARE MAKING
CONCERTED EFFORTS TO DO
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT. BUT HAVE
NO WHERE TO TAKE THE VEGETATE
THE MET THE VEGETATION IS BEEN
MANAGE- AND THAT IS THAT IS
PROBLEMATIC- WOULD NEED TO HAUL
THIS AS FAR IF WE HAD MORE. WE
COULD REACTIVATE SOME OF THE
EXISTING BY MAP BIOMASS PLANTS
THAT HAVE. BEEN CLOSED OVER THE
YEARS. THAT'S A WHOLE NOTHER
ISSUE. WHEN YOU DO SOME OF THIS
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WHAT'S
ALSO NOT BEING CONSIDERED HERE
IS THAT- IT ALLOWS THE FORCE TO
BECOME HEALTHIER. WHICH ALLOWS
THE TREES TO BECOME BIGGER.
WHICH ALLOWS US TO SEQUESTER
MORE CARBON. THERE IS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFIT TO WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE LEAVING
THE FUELS ON THE FOREST FLOOR.
LEADS TO METHANE RELEASE OVER
TIME ALSO IS ANOTHER POTENTIAL
FUEL SOURCE FOR ADDITIONAL FIRES
IN THE FUTURE. IT ISN'T AN
EFFICIENT WAY TO PRODUCE ENERGY.
IT WON'T BE AN EFFICIENT WAY TO
PRODUCE ENERGY. AND WE SHOULDN'T
BE LOOKING AT IT THAT WAY I
THINK WE SHOULD LOOK AND BE
LOOKING AT THIS AS A LARGER
SOCIETAL BENEFIT. IS IT DO WE
REALLY WANT OUR CHILDREN. AND R.
AND A AND OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE
FRAIL TO CONTINUE TO HAVE TO
BRIEF- PARTICULAR MATTER PM
TWENTY TWO POINT FIVE WHICH IS
REALLY REALLY UNHEALTHY. DO WE
REALLY WANT THAT. OR DO WE WANT
TO LOOK AT SOME OTHER THINGS
RECOGNIZING THAT THAT THERE ARE
COMPROMISES THAT THERE ARE.
THERE THERE IS THERE IS THERE IS
NO PERFECT SOLUTION WE DON'T
HAVE THAT PERFECT SOLUTION YET.
AND SO- I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY- I BELIEVE- IT'S IN
THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT THE PEOPLE
THAT I REPRESENT. AND- I HOPE
THAT TO I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
PROCEDURE LEAVE IF HE'S NOT WHAT
HE'S OFFERING WORKS FOR YOU AS A
CHAIR- BUT- I'M NOT TO SHARE
THIS WITH SO ANYWAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR WET AND- YOU KNOW
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER FOR
PRESENTING THIS BILL- YOU KNOW
I. WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY- MAINLY BECAUSE- I
BELIEVE THAT DID YOU ARE A FUNDS
SHOULD BE USED TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
WHAT THIS BILL IS PROPOSING. IS
TO SUBSIDIZE THE TRUCKING OF
THIS MATERIAL PUT PERHAPS LONG
DISTANCES- AND YOU KNOW I FEEL
LIKE IT'S MOVING IN THAT PROBLEM
SOMEWHERE ELSE. RIGHT THEY ARE
QUALITY ISSUES- I THINK THIS
COULD BE MORE. PROPERLY A BUDGET
REQUEST OF LIKE- I THINK SOMEONE
ELSE MENTIONED ARE AND- YOU KNOW
I AGREE WITH YOU THERE IS A
CHALLENGE WITH. BIOMASS
TREATMENT AND UTILIZATION- BUT-
I DON'T FEEL LIKE THIS IS THE
SOLUTION AND IF IT'S NOT ONE
THAT I CAN SUPPORT AND I KNOW
PEOPLE HAVE MENTIONED THAT. THIS
BILL WAS PRESENTED AN AMENDED IN
THE PAST I WASN'T THE CHAIR AT
THE TIME AND I DIDN'T SERVE ON
THE COMMITTEE. ARE AND SO I MADE
THIS DECISION- TO NOT SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY- AND- YOU I HOPE
THAT I KNOW YOU WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS SITE A- YOU'LL
COMMEND YOU FOR YOUR PASSION.
FOR SERVING THE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE SUFFERED MOST FROM
WILDFIRES IN OUR STATE- BUT I
WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING TODAY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN-
CHAIRWOMAN AND- WHAT I WOULD
PROPOSE TO THE COMMITTEE IS- I
WILL TAKE. IF YOU WOULD MOVING
TODAY I WOULD ASK THAT IT BE
MOVED AS AMENDED- AND SO I'D ASK
FOR THE SUPPORT OF THE
COMMITTEE- I WILL ABSOLUTELY
TAKE THE AMENDMENT THAT SAYS-
THESE THESE CANNOT BE APPLIED TO
BIOMASS PLANTS THAT ARE IN NON
ATTAINMENT AREAS- AND I DISAGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE. MISTER WOULD
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE WILL TAKE
THESE PLACES CUTS AND WE WILL
TAKE THEM BELIEVE ME BECAUSE WE
HAVE. WE HAVE A TEAM IN OUR
AREAS AND WE NEED THESE
DESPERATELY TO REMOVE THE FEELS-
AND TO MAKE OUR COMMUNITY SAFER
AND FOR THE JOBS QUITE FRANKLY-
SO I WOULD ABSOLUTELY TAKE THAT.
THAT AMENDMENT I THINK THAT
ADDRESSES WE'RE NOT ADDING. NEW
POLLUTANTS INTO AN AREA THAT'S
ALREADY IN NON ATTAINMENT- I
WOULD ALSO TAKE THE AMENDMENT
WOULD ASK IS A I HAVE AN
AMENDMENT THAT TO. AND THAT SAYS
IT. THIS CAN APPLY TO THOSE THAT
ARE ALREADY GETTING THE NINE OH
ONE- MONEY- UNTIL THERE UNTIL
THAT CONTRACT IS EXPIRED IN
WHICH CASE AND THEY COULD APPLY
AT THAT POINT. SO THOSE
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD REALLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT MOVE FOR AND ON
THE ON THE TRUCKING SAID JUST
ASK YOU TO CONSIDER I MEAN. YOU
KNOW WHEN WE BRING IN SOLAR
PANELS. TO BE PUT IN AND
INSTALLED AND FACILITIES AND- ON
HOMES THEY'RE TRUCKED IN HERE
WOULD DIESEL TRUCKS. OKAY WE
BRING IN THE BIG WINDMILL
COMPONENTS TO DO WIND ENERGY.
THEY'RE TRUCKED IN BY DIESEL
TRUCKS. NOW I CAN'T CHANGE THE
FACT OF WHAT IS MOVING IN ALL
KINDS OF GOODS. IN CALIFORNIA
BUT WHAT I CAN DO IN THIS IS I
THINK THE- IT'S A BIT OF A RED
HERRING BECAUSE IT'S NOT ABOUT
THE TRUCKING IT'S ACTUALLY ABOUT
THE BIOMASS FACILITY ITSELF
WHICH IS WHERE THAT. WOODY
BIOMASS IS DISPOSED OF IN THE
MOST ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE
WAY AND WE GOT IT WE HAVE TO
INVEST IN THAT TECHNOLOGY WE
NEED TO MAKE IT EVEN BIGGER LIKE
WE HAVE DONE. IN OTHER ASK
AVENUES AND THIS WOULD DO THAT.
THIS WOULD BE THAT INCENTIVE
THAT WOULD BUILD MORE THESE
BIOMASS PLANTS BECAUSE THEN THE
COST. IT WORKS OUT. THEN IF YOU
HAVE SOMEBODY HELPING SUBSIDIZE
THE COST OF THE TRANSPORTATION
WHICH IS THERE. THEIR BIGGEST
HARD COST- SO I REALLY ASK YOU
DID FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION- WITH
THOSE AMENDMENT TO THIS BILL ASK
YOU TO VOTE YES TO MOVE THIS.
MOVE THIS FORWARD. ARE YOU KNOW
I. THAT THAT'S YOU DID MENTION
SOME AMENDMENTS THAT OF THOSE
AREN'T AMENDMENTS THAT I
PROPOSED RIGHT OF AND- YOU KNOW
YOU. IF YOU WANT TO CHANGE THE
SPELL IT YOU KNOW YOU'RE WELCOME
TO INTRODUCE A NEW BILL. AS YOU
KNOW AS YOU KNOW THIS IS THE TO
YOUR BILLS I HAVE NOT HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE. OF THE
BILL IN WHATEVER WAY YOU WANT TO
AMENDMENT- SO I WILL. CONTINUE
TO NOT. THE BILL IN THIS FORM
TODAY. R. N. AND I KNOW THAT ONE
OFFICIAL COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS-
THEY WERE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
IN THE PREVIOUS LEGISLATION THAT
CAME TO THE COMMITTEE NO I
UNDERSTAND SO I KNOW AND THAT
COMMITTEE STAFF. AND MY STAFF
HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT THESE
AMENDMENTS SO. IT'S ALL VERY
CLEAR IN WRITING SO IF THE
COMMITTEE WANTED TO- YOU KNOW.
DOZEN MEMBERS COULD EASILY BE
MADE AS PART OF A MOTION TO
AMEND THE BILL AND MOVE IT OUT
OF COMMITTEE TODAY AND THAT'S
WHAT I WOULD ASK IF THE
COMMITTEE IS AMENABLE TO THAT. I
AM NOT TODAY R. N. AND SO WE
WILL BE VOTING ON THE BILL AS IS
IN PRINT. TODAY I'M SO I HAVE A
MOTION OF THE TO MOVE THE BILL
BY MISTER MATHIS SECOND- BY
MISTER FLORA THE MOTION IS TO
PASS. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS RIVAS NO
RIVAS NO FLOOR- FLUORIDE BENNETT
NOT VOTING. GARCIA. MATHIS FIVE
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY NOW MCCARTY
NO WHERE TO CHECK OUT TO CHINO
REYES NO RAISE NO ZERO. STONE
STONE NO WHAT ARE WHAT I. THE
BILL HAS THREE VOTES RIGHT NOW
WITH THANK I'M A PLACE ON CALL.
WE ARE READY FOR ITEM FIVE AB
NINE FORTY THREE BY MR GARCIA.
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES- MEDIC
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO PRESENT THIS BILL WE WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT TO NOT JUST JUMP RIGHT
IN THE BILL WOULD FURTHER
REQUIRE AGENCIES TO. ALLOW AT
LEAST THREE MONTHS BETWEEN THE
CALL FOR APPLICATIONS AND
DEADLINE AND WILL REQUIRE A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE REPORT ON
APPLICATIONS RECEIVED TO HELP
STATE UNDERSTAND WHERE THERE ARE
GAPS OR BARRIERS TO ACCESSING
THESE IMPORTANT RESOURCES. THIS
HAS TO DO WITH THE COUNTIES OF
SAN DIEGO AND IMPERIAL COUNTY
WHO ARE ADJACENT TO AN
INTERNATIONAL BORDER. SEE AN
INFLUX OF CLOSE TO TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE A DAY COMING
INTO THOSE COUNTIES ARE IMPACTED
BY. AIR QUALITY AND OTHER.
LINEMATE RELATED TYPE OF ISSUES
AND- WANTING TO SEE THESE
REGIONS OF THE STATE BE MORE
COMPETITIVE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
CLIMATE INVESTMENT DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK. BECAUSE WE ARE
WORKING SERVICE. OKAY I'M SO.
WE'RE READY FOR- WITNESSES AND
SO DO WE HAVE A MEASURE WE HAVE
ANY APOLOGIZE WE DON'T HAVE THE
LEST WE DON'T WRITE NOT I DON'T
BELIEVE SO I'M NOT I DON'T THINK
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION REGISTER. SO SORRY WE
ARE VERIFYING RIGHT NOW. NOW
OKAY. PHOTOGRAPH WHICH WAS A
GREAT SO WE WERE MOVE ON- ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. I WANTS TO
REGISTER SUPPORTER OPPOSITION.
OKAY OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES. ABSOLUTELY TO
SHOW SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY NINE FORTY THREE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE A LINE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEIR LINE NUMBER. OPERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES ON THE LINE
YES WE HAVE- WE DO HAVE A LINE
READY NOW WHERE WE WILL OPEN UP
LINE SIXTY SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY THIS IS ERIC
BRONSON ON BEHALF OF THE
IMPERIAL COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB NINE FORTY THREE. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANKS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY SEEN NONE OF WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU. SO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL I HAVE A
MOTION SIR HAVE A MOTION FOR
MISTER WOULD SECONDED BY MR SEAH
. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS RIVAS I
REQUEST I FLOOR THE FLOOR NO
BENNETT HI. I GARCIA. GARCIA I
MATHIS BOB. MCCARTY THANK
MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
I. REYES REYES ISENGARD STONE
STONE I WOULD. WOOD I. THE BILL
HAS EIGHT VOTES- WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN. SO HE'S HE'S KIND OF
PERCENT OF THE PRESIDENT. OKAY
I'M SO I BELIEVE YOU'RE
PRESENTING A C. R. ONE OH NINE
ALSO YES I HAD I WILL BE
PRESENTING ACR ONE NINE
RESOLUTION ORIGINALLY BROUGHT
FORTH BY SOME REMEMBER. LAURA
GONZALEZ AT THE MEASURE WITH THE
CARE CALIFORNIA'S LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZING- THAT EXTREME HEAT
POSES A MAJOR THREAT TO THE
PUBLIC OUT THE WELL BEING.
CALIFORNIANS MANY COMMUNITIES
AND WE'RE ASKING DEPARTMENTS
OTHER AGENCIES TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO PROTECT THE THESE
COMMUNITIES RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS AS WELL.
THANK YOU MR GARCIA I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE WITNESSES
REGISTERED IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM LIKE TO REGISTER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. OKAY SEE
NINE OPERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO ACR ONE
OH NINE. THANK YOU AND TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCHTONE
PHONE AT THIS TIME. MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE CHEWED UP FROM
THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU I'M
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
MEMBERS. C. NINE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE JUST A THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE I
KNOW WE WILL BE TAG TEAMING ON A
COUPLE OF OTHER. RELATED MATTERS
AND THE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIFLE OKAY WE ARE AMENDING
THIS MOTION I'M TO CHANGE THE
AUTHOR TO MR GARCIA- SO OUR
MOTION IS AMENDED BE ADOPTED AS
AMENDED I'M SECRETARY Q. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
RIVAS HI RIVAS HI FLORA ARE
FLOOR AYE BENNETT AYE BENNETT
AYE GARCIA GARCIA I MATHIS. FIVE
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY THANK. RT
ARMOR TO CHECK. THREE G. REYES.
REYES I SEE ARTICLE. STONE STONE
I WOULD. WHAT I. THE BILL HAS
TEN BOTH. THANK YOU LEAVE WE ARE
MAY A MEMBER RIGHT YES MISTER
SIRE TO OKAY SO WE WILL LEAVE
THAT OPEN THANK YOU MR GARCIA.
YES SO WEHAVE A MOTION BY MISS
GARCIA TO MOVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SECOND BY MISTER WOULD.
SECRETARY Q. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS RIVAS
HI RIVAS I FLORA FLOOR AYE
BENNETT AYE BENNETT AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I MATHIS- MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI READ SU CHI I REYES.
REYES I SAY ORDER STONE STONE I
WOULD. WHAT I. THE BILL HAS TEN
VOTES. YEAH WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN. OUR NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO
AB ONE THOUSAND ONE I MISS
GARCIA. SIMILAR POLICY THERE-
THREE. OKAY I AM SO SORRY I DO
NOT MR PATTERSON IN THE ROOM SO
YES SORRY I WAS SO PLEASED AT
THE MISTER PATTERSON. HE WILL BE
PRESENTING AB ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR. I HAVE A PREFERRED CHAIR HERE
. I DIDN'T I BELIEVE BOTH MY EX
ARE ON RIGHT. THE FACT YEAH-
PLEASE MAKE YOURSELF COMFORTABLE
AND PHILLIES PLEASE START WHEN
YOU'RE READY HI I'M YEAH I'M
READY- THIS IS A- EIGHT EIGHT
ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR- FOR. CREATING
A SEQUEL EXEMPTION FOR EGRESS
ROUTE- PROJECTS FOR FIRE SAFETY
FOR THE SAFETY OF INDIVIDUALS IN
THE- HIGH FIRE AREAS TO HAVE- A
STREAMLINED WAY OF GETTING THESE
EGRESS AND- ROADS ARE TAUGHT TO
SAY THANK YOU FIRST OF ALL FOR.
THE HARD WORK THE COMMITTEES
DONE- BLOOD TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
AUTHORED AB TWO NINE ONE ONE
REQUIRING THE BOARD OF FORESTRY
AND FIRE PROTECTION. TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT IMPROVE THE
FIRE SAFETY OF EXISTING
SUBDIVISIONS THAT DON'T HAVE A
SECONDARY EXIT RIGHT LESS THAN.
TWO MONTHS AFTER AB TWENTY NINE
ELEVEN WAS SIGNED INTO LAW THE
CAMPFIRE REP DID. TORE THROUGH
THE CITY OF PARADISE IT KILLED
EIGHTY SIX PEOPLE DESTROYING
NEARLY. FOURTEEN THOUSAND HOMES
SO. BECAME OBVIOUS THAT THE
CAPACITY PROBLEMS
NOTWITHSTANDING OF PARADISE AT
FOUR ROUTES TO GET RESIDENTS OUT
OF TOWN IN THE EVENT OF
EMERGENCY. THAT WHILE MANY OTHER
COMMUNITIES HAVE ONLY ONE. HAD
THIS BEEN THE CASE IN PARADISE
WE COULD EXPECT THE DEATH TOLL
MUCH MUCH HIGHER. SO THE BILL
BEFORE YOU PROVIDES A SEQUEL
EXEMPTION FOR PROJECTS
RECOMMENDED. BY THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
THAT IMPROVE THE FIRE SAFETY OF
EXISTING SUBDIVISIONS THAT ARE
LOCATED IN HIGH OR VERY HIGH
FIRE HAZARD ZONES. AND WHO DO
NOT HAVE ENOUGH EXIT ROUTES TO
GET RESIDENTS OUT SAFELY. A
PREVIOUS VERSION OF THIS BILL
WAS PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
BUT WAS VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR
HOWEVER THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT
NOW MORE THAN EVER IN LIGHT OF
THE INCREASING NUMBER AND THE
SEVERITY OF THE FIRES THAT SWEEP
ACROSS THE STATE EACH YEAR. I
KNOW THE CREEK FIRE THE DIXIE
FIRE THE CAL FIVE OUT OF FIVE
JUST TO NAME A FEW THE BOARDHAS
NOW RELEASED. SUBDIVISION
REVIEWS MAKING IT THE PERFECT
TIME TO IMPLEMENT THIS POLICY TO
PROTECT THESE COMMUNITIES BEFORE
IT IS TOO LATE. AB ELEVEN FIFTY
FOUR IS NEEDED SO THAT THESE
PROJECTS THOSE THAT ARE IN HIGH
AND VERY HIGH SECURITY A
SEVERITY ZONES. CAN BE COMPLETED
WITH THE URGENCY IDENTIFIED BY
THE BOARD FORCED FOUR STRAIGHT.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I
BELIEVE IT'S JOHN KENNEDY ON THE
PHONE. WITH A RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE BUTTE COUNTY SUPERVISOR
JOHN. TEETER WHO REPRESENTS
PARADISE. THANK YOU. OPERATE WE
ARE READY FOR WITNESSES SUPPORT
WILL START WITH JOHN KENNEDY.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN JOHN
KENNEDY WITH RC RC AND WE'RE
VERY PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB
ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR TODAY I'D
REITERATE WE REALLY APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS AND
COMMITTEE STAFF TO IMPROVE AND
REFINE THIS BILL HAS THE AUTHOR
SAID THIS BILL SEEKS TO CREATE A
NARROW SICKLE EXEMPTION AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF CIRCUMSTANCES
FOR THE CREATION OF SECONDARY
INGRESS ROUTES. WHERE
SUBDIVISIONS ARE AT HIGH FIRE
RISK AND DON'T HAVE A SECONDARY
EGRESS ROUTE FOR THE RESIDENTS
TO GET OUT SAFELY IN THE EVENT
OF AN EMERGENCY. I THINK MAYBE
MY OFFICE NOTES MANY OF THESE
SUBDIVISIONS WERE BUILT LONG AGO
AND ONLY HAVE A SINGLE ROUTE FOR
ENTERING AND LEAVING THIS BILL
WILL ADDRESS THE RISK OF ROAD
CLOSURE DURING AN EMERGENCY AND
CONGESTION DURING AN EMERGENCY
BY EXPEDITING CREATION OF
SECONDARY ROUTES IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. AS HAS BEEN STATED
REASON WILDFIRES OF TAKING A
TREMENDOUS TOLL ON RESOURCES
COMMUNITIES IN LIVES LOST- WITH
FOUR POINT TWO MILLION AND TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION ACRES OF
CALIFORNIA BURNED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE
WILDFIRES RESPECTIVELY AND TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
DISPLACED BY THOSE FIRES. THE
DEADLY CAMPFIRE WHICH YOU'LL
HEAR MORE LATER- WAS THE
DEADLIEST WILDFIRE IN STATE
HISTORY AND DEMONSTRATED THE
PRESSING NEED PROGRESS ROUTES
WHILE AB THREE NINETY FOUR WAS
VETOED IN TWENTY NINETEEN WE
AGREED THAT THESE CIRCUMSTANCES
HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGED THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY HAVE NOT YET
IDENTIFIED NOR MADE ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS OR COMMUNITY AT
THE TIME OF THREE NINETY FORESEE
TELL. BUT THE BOARD HAS DONE SO
NOW AND THEY'VE ADOPTED
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR PERHAPS A
THIRD OF THOSE SO FAR WITH MORE
ON THE WAY. TO SPONSOR ELEVEN
NINE FIFTY FOUR BECAUSE IT WILL
HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENTS GET THE
SECONDARY EGRESS ROUTE PROJECTS
BUILT FASTER AND REDUCE COSTS
VOIDING THE POTENTIAL CRITICAL
LITIGATION THAT COULD INCREASE
PROJECT COSTS AND DELAY
COMPLETION. THIS IS BECAUSE THE
BAR FOR FILING CLAIMS IS SO VERY
WELL WHEN IT DOESN'T TAKE MUCH
FOR PROJECT UPON. TO DELAY A
PROJECT. ALL COURT CONSIDERS THE
COR. THESE ARE THE WAY. THE MANY
WERE COMMUNITY CANNOT. AND SO WE
ARE HERE I TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK NEXT WERE READY FOR
SUPERVISOR TEETER. I THINK YOU-
OBVIOUSLY- AND VERY STRONG
SUPPORTOF THE IN THE BUTTE
COUNTY SUPERVISOR THAT POTS TO
SOME OF THE CAMPFIRE IF YOU
DON'T MIND DAHLE SHARE MY
PERSONAL STORY- THE DAY OF THE
CAMPFIRE I EVACUATED FROM MY
HOUSE I NEEDED A QUARTER MILE
AWAY I HAD TO SHELTER IN PLACE.
A WOMAN PERISHED IN A VEHICLE
NOT FAR FROM LONDON SHELTERED IN
PLACE- ALSO AGAIN MAKE YOU
RECALL A JEWISH NAME FOR PEOPLE
PERISHED IN I DON'T. NEED A
LECTURE THAT THIS HORRIFIC STORY
BUT IT'S JUST IT'S. SUCH A
STRONG- FEELING ME. TO HAVE THAT
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AND I HAD TO
REMOVE EXIT ROUTES. AVAILABLE
FROM MY HOUSE ONE ONE THE LEGEND
OF THE FIRE ONE I PROBABLY WOULD
HAVE GOT TO SAFETY QUICKLY IF I
WILL BE USED TO IT- BUT I TOLD
MY WIFE TO GO PICK UP MY
CHILDREN. AT SCHOOL IN THE
CENTER OF TOWN. AND IT JUST
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE JUST A UNIQUE
SITUATION- WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED
IN THE DIXIE FIRING PRETTY BILL
AND ALSO RECENTLY WITH COLORADO.
AND A GRAND SLAM FIRE SO- I URGE
FOR YOUR YES VOTE AND I THINK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. WE
DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESS READ. TO
TEST NOT. SO WE WILL OPEN IT UP
TO. AN ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WILL START
WITH THOSE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN MADAM CHAIR
CHRIS MCNALLY ON BEHALF OF
HUMBOLDT REDWOOD COMPANY IN
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
HEY OERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES TWO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS
TIME. WE WILL FIRST MOVE GO TO
LINE SIXTY FOUR GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS THE ONLY GATHERED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY SEVEN.
ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AB ONE ZERO BUT THEY
DIDN'T GIVE ME A NUMBER- IF
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE A SPEAKER ON
THE CONFERENCE CALL YOUR LINE IS
ALREADY OPEN WE WOULD NOT BE
PULLING YOUR LINE FROM THE CALL-
NINE FORTY SEVEN IF YOU WOULD
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO CAN WE CAN
TRY TO OPEN YOUR LINE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BRING LIGHT ON BEHALF OF FORCE
LANDOWNERS OF CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT. WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE
SIXTY NINE GO AHEAD. HELLO IS
THIS PATTERSON BILL YEAH THIS IS
IT AB ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR OKAY.
YES I KNOW ABOUT YOU CHAIR
REVIVED I SUPPORT THIS BILL THAT
YOU DON'T FOLLOW THE AGENDA YOU
SUBSTITUTE PEOPLE LAND FOR BILLS
YOU DIDN'T GIVE PEOPLE A CHANCE
TO SPEAK ABOUT THAT WILL RAIN
NOTHING THAT ONE OH NINE THAT SO
HORRIFIC AND SUCH A WASTE OF
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
CAN QUEUE THIS TIME MEDICARE.
THANK YOU. ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. K.
C. NINE WOULD YOU LIKE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR NO WE LET YOU GO
BECAUSE YOU WERE THE ONLY AUTHOR
THAT IT'S NOT ON THE COMMITTEE
IN THE ROOM AT A TIME TO STAND
THAT I. HAVE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENTING- THE
THESE ARE SERIOUS CRIMES WE
STRUGGLE THROUGH THE CAMP FIRE
IN MY IN MY DISTRICT. OBVIOUSLY
THE IMPORTANCE OF GETTING YOU
GRASS ROADS- AND DONE DONE IN A
TIMELY WAY- IS GOING TO SIX SAVE
LIVES BUT IT'S ALSO GOING TO
PROVIDE. OUR FIREFIGHTERS WITH
ROUTES TO FART FIGHT THE FIRE
GET IN. GET GET. THE FIRES
KNOCKED DOWN AND PEOPLE SAY IT'S
OKAY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. YOUR
SUPPORT ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE A MOTION
SECOND OKAY SO. A MOVE BY MR FOR
A SECOND BY MISTER MATHIS THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
RIVAS HI RIVAS HI FLORA FLORA
IBENIK. AND IT AYE GARCIA AYE
GARCIA AYE MATHIS- MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI. MURATSUCHI I. REYES
. REYES ICY GARDA STONE STONEHAM
WOOD HI. I GET APPLE HAS NINE
VOTES AND WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR MEMBERS THAT ARE NOT PRESENT
THANK. NEXT WE HAVE AB TEN
SEVENTY EIGHT ALSO BY MR
PATTERSON PLEASE GO AHEAD. START. AGAIN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
MEMBERS APPRECIATE THE- WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND ANNA AND
APPRECIATE- YOUR RECOGNITION OF
THE BILL'S IMPORTANCE AND I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND THANK YOU
IN TWENTY NINETEEN AB ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW THIS BILL PROVIDED AN
EXEMPTION TO THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION RULING THAT
REQUIRED ALL NEWLY CONSTRUCTED
HOMES IN THE STATE THAT SOLAR
PANELS. BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY THE EXEMPTION WAS ONLY
FOR VICTIMS WHOSE HOMES WERE
DESTROYED IN A NATURAL DISASTER
THAT OCCURRED DURING A GOVERNOR
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY
ADDITIONALLY FOR THE EXEMPTION
TO APPLY INCOME SQUARE FOOTAGE
CAN OR INSURANCE REQUIREMENTS
DID HAVE TO BE MET. THIS IS A
NARROW EXEMPTION TO THE CVC
REQUIREMENT FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION
IS GEARED TOWARDS A LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE BEING
FORCED TO REBUILD THEIR HOME
THAT WAS DESTROYED THROUGH NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN AB TEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WOULD SIMPLY
EXTEND THE PROVISIONS OF AB ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT. TO NAURAL
DISASTERS THAT OCCURRED IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO ENSURE THAT THE
VICTIMS THAT WERE. LOOKED AFTER
AND HELPED IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
ARE ALSO NOW HELPED AND PROVIDED
UP. WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO
REBUILD WITHOUT THAT THE EXTREME
COST OF THE OF THE SOLAR PANELS
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY- DISASTERS
TWENTY TWENTY WAS A YEAR WHEN
MANY LOST NOT ONLY THEIR HOMES
BUT- CRAPS LOVED ONES AS WELL
AND LIVELIHOODS DUE TO COVER
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
WILDFIRES. INCLUDE SOME OF THE
LARGEST THEY INCLUDED THE AUGUST
COMPLEX THE S. C. U. LIGHTNING
COMPLEX THE L. N. U. LIGHTNING
COMPLEX. THE GLASS ZAUGG AND THE
CREEK FIRE. AND SO I THINK. WITH
RESPECT RESPECTIVELY. SOME OF
THE OPPOSITION- I THINK THAT
THESE ARE VICTIMS AND THAT THAT
THEY SHOULD NOT BE FORCED TO
INSTALL. SOLAR PANELS SINCE THEY
ARE BUILDING NEW CONSTRUCTION.
IT IS BASICALLY LOOKING PAST
THEIR THEIR BAD FORTUNE AND- NOT
WRECKED RECOGNIZING THAT IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT COST. TO MANY UP IN
THESE AREAS. IF THEIR HOMES WERE
STILL STANDING THEY WOULD NOT BE
FACING THIS KIND OF A DECISION.
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN UPGRADING. OR LEAVING
THE COMMUNITY OUT OR THE AREA.
THESE ARE NOT INVESTORS OR REAL
ESTATE MOGULS. THESE ARE VICTIMS
WHO ARE TRYING TO COME BACK
HOME. THEY'RE BUILDING A NEW
CONSTRUCTION HOME NOT BY CHOICE
BUT BY NECESSITY. GIVEN THE
RISING COST OF THESE REBUILT THE
CHANGES TO NET ENERGY METERING
THE FACT THAT MANY OF THESE
VICTIMS ALREADY DO NOT HAVE
ENOUGH INSURANCE. TO COVER THE
COST OF REBUILDING AS IT IS AB
TEN SEVENTY EIGHT IS AN
APPROPRIATE AND A LIMITED
MEASURE. TO HELP YOU TO THE
BURDEN OF REBUILDING ONE'S LIFE
AFTER ALL OF WHICH TO STRIVE. BY
THE WILDFIRE. AND I DO THINK
THAT THERE IS ALSO. A REAL ISSUE
OF- FAIRNESS HERE AS WELL.
TWENTY NINETEEN HAD VICTIMS AND
HAD. BOB THIS EXEMPTION TWENTY
TWENTY LOTS OF VICTIMS. IT
SHOULD HAVE THIS EXEMPTION AS
WELL. AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I BELIEVE
WE HAVE AREA RAIL- PREVIOUS
CHAIRED THE CREEK FIRE RECOVERY
COLLABORATIVE. I THINK A JOHN
KENNEDY AS WELL WITH A RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES. K.
TESTIFIED SUPPORT THANK YOU- WE
ARE READY FOR WITNESSES. UP
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. OPERATOR
Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE IT
WAS I MISSED THE FIRST NAME I
DON'T HAVE THEM LISTED- ARI
ARROYO ARI A ROYAL IS HE
AVAILABLE THE CHAIR OF THE CREEK
FIRE RECOVERY NOT COLLABORATIVE-
FIRST HAND ON THE GROUND
EXPERIENCE WITH THESE HOME
OWNERS TRYING TO REBUILD IN
FACING THE CONSEQUENCES OF HIGH
COST. OPERATOR WE ARE READY I'M
HERE A PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY
NAME IS ARE YOU LOYAL AND I
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN SEVENTY EIGHT. I LIVE
IN PHILLY CALIFORNIA. AND I AM A
FIREFIGHTER ON THE PINE RIDGE
FIRE DEPARTMENT ON THE BOARD OF
THE PRIME WHICH PROPERTY OWNERS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS THE
FORMER CHAIR OF THE CREEK FIRE
RECOVERY COLLABORATIVE. I WOULD
HEAR THROUGHOUT THE FIRE
FIGHTING THE FIRE AND I KNOW THE
RESIDENTS AND THIS IS HOME. I AM
HERE MOST IMPORTANTLY IS A FULL
TIME RESIDENT AND ONE OF THE FEW
WHO DID NOT LOSE THEIR HOME IN
THE CREEK FIRE. BECAUSE I WAS SO
LUCKY TO HAVE BEEN MY GOAL TO DO
EVERYTHING AND ANYTHING I CAN TO
AID THOSE WHO LOST EVERYTHING IN
THE FIRE. AB TEN SEVENTY EIGHT
IS OF THE UTMOST IMPORTANCE TO
AID IN THE RECOVERY AND
REBUILDING OF OUR MOUNTAIN
COMMUNITIES. THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN TO THOSE WHO LOST THEIR
HOMES AND EVERYTHING THEY OWNED
DUE TO THE CREEK FIRE. AS WELL
AS THE OTHER CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRES IT'S ASTRONOMICAL AND
THE ADDED REQUIREMENTS SOLAR
PANELS IS A HUGE BURDEN WHICH
CAN IN SOME INSTANCES. MEDICALLY
BUILDING UNVIABLE. IN MY
COMMUNITY ALONE WE LOST 75% OF
OUR HOME. AND ALMOST ALL OF
THOSE HOMEOWNERS WITH TOLD ME
THAT THEY WANT TO BE BUILT. THEY
HAVE HOWEVER ALSO STATED THAT
DUE TO THE TOUGH ECONOMY WE ARE
IN. AND THE HIGH COST OF
BUILDING INCLUDING ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS SOLAR
PANELS BUT UNABLE TO DO SO AT
THIS TIME. I CANNOT FULLY
EXPRESS HOW IT BREAKS YOUR HEART. TO HAVE YOUR NEIGHBOR TELL
YOU. SORRY WITH. ARE IS. BUT
THEIR GREATEST WEAKNESS COME
BACK HOME. BUT WE CAN AFFORD TO.
WITHOUT AB TWO SEVEN EIGHT NOT
ONLY WILL MANY NOT BE ABLE TO
REBUILD. MAYBE FORCED TO LEAVE
THEIR COMMUNITY IMPOSSIBLE EVEN
COMPLETED THE STATE. YEAH
COUNTLESS FINANCIAL COULDN'T
HURDLES TO CROSS AND IF WE CAN
ALLEVIATE AT LEAST ONE OF THOSE
HRDLES BY PASSING AB TEN
SEVENTY EIGHT THE IMPACT WILL BE
HUGE. SORRY ON BEHALF OF ALL
THOSE WHO LOST THEIR HOMES ONE
OF THE CALIFORNIA WIRE BOTTOM
FIRED WE ASK THAT YOU VOTE IN
FAVOR OF A. B. TEN SEVENTY EIGHT
. THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK HERE. THANK YOU NEXT
AND WE'RE READY FOR JOHN KENNEDY. GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN JOHN
KENNEDY WITH RC RC WE ARE
PLEASED TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT AB
TEN SEVENTY EIGHT AS WELL AND
ALL START BY SAYING ALL SCRAPPED
MOST OF MY TESTIMONY AS IT'S
ALREADY BEEN COVERED BY MR
PATTERSON- BUT I DO WANT TO
REITERATE YOU KNOW OUR MEMBER
COUNTIES HAVE SUFFERED A LOT OF
FROM A LOT OF THE STATE'S RECENT
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES. AND MANY
OF THESE FIRES SYSTEMS THAT WERE
IN SOCIO ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED AREAS THE VICTIMS
ARE INCREASINGLY FINDING
THEMSELVES UNDER INSURED OR
UNABLE TO ACQUIRE INSURANCE AND
ALSO FACE MANY OTHER WHEN HE
DELAYS ASSOCIATED WITH BUILDING
THEIR HOMES WE APPRECIATE THAT
ABC TEN SEVENTY EIGHT AS A
LIMITED ONE YEAR EXT EXTENSION
OF THE DAILY EXEMPTION- FOUR
HOMES DESTROYED BEFORE TWENTY
TWENTY. IT PROVIDES VERY MUCH
NEEDED RELIEF FOR THOSE
RESIDENTS WHOSE HOMES WERE
DAMAGED OR DESTROYED AND TWENTY
TWENTY WHILE IT IS ADMITTEDLY
LESS EXPENSIVE TO INSTALL SOLAR
PANELS ON A NEWLY CONSTRUCTED
HOME IT CAN STILL BE VERY
EXPENSIVE AND THOSE ARE UP FRONT
COSTS FOR REBUILDING A HOME.
WHILE THE PAY BACK PERIOD MAY BE
OVER TEN FIFTEEN TWENTY YEARS OR
OR LONGER DEPENDING ON THE
INSTALLATION ITS UP FRONT COST
AND THOSE HURT- AND THAT MAKES
REBUILDING HARDER AND MORE
EXPENSIVE AS MR PATTERSON SAID
FOR THOSE WHO'VE ALREADY LOST
EVERYTHING AND THEY MAY NOT HAVE
THE RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES. FURTHERMORE
AS NOTED THE PSC IS POISED TO
REVISE THE SOLAR NET ENERGY
METERING TARIFF- AND IN A WAY IT
IF AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN AND
COMPOSED IN A WAY THAT WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE O
TWITTER WORKABLE COSTS FOR ALL
HOMEOWNERS WITH SOLAR THIS COULD
HAVE AN EVEN MORE AGGRESSIVE
IMPACT IN SOME OF THESE VERY
DEVASTATED COMMUNITIES SO FOR
THESE AND OTHER REASONS WE
AREN'T YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB.
SEVENTY EIGHT AND APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION. TO THAT.
THANK YOU. I'M NEXT ARE WE WILL
HEAR FROM THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- WE HAVE DANIEL BROAD
FROM THE SIERRA CLUB OF
CALIFORNIA. AND KIM STONE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION-
WE'LL START WITH DANIEL. AND
DINNER BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION A. TEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. WHICH WOULD
CONTINUE TO EXEMPT COUNTY BEING
REBUILT AFTER SPECIFIED
EMERGENCY EVENT. FROM MEETING
ROOFTOP SOLAR REQUIREMENTS. WE
DEEPLY SYMPATHIZE WITH THE
VICTIMS OF WILDFIRES AND OTHER
DISASTERS AND RECOGNIZE THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN OF REBUILDING
WE ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT
APPROPRIATE MEASURES TO HELP
COMMUNITIES RECOVER. HOWEVER
EXEMPTING BUILDING CODE
REQUIREMENTS THAT WILL REDUCE
ENERGY YEARS MAY COME TOMORROW
AT THE END AND LOWER ELECTRICITY
BALLOTS IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
ONLY A TRIP CAL IMPROVEMENTS
THAT WILL ENSURE. THAT ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MEASURES REQUIRED
UNDER NEW BUILDING CODES DAVE
MARTIN YOU'RE TELLING ME ABOUT
THE NET COST. THAT RESULTS IN
HOMEOWNER SAVING ENERGY FROM THE
DAY THEY MOVED AND THROUGHOUT
THE LIFETIME OF THE HOUSE.
ADDITIONALLY WILDFIRE BRETT'S
KIDS FORCED FREQUENT PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF IN RECENT
YEARS. AT THE CLIMATE CRISIS
WORSENS. THESE EVENTS WILL
UNFORTUNATELY BECOME EVEN MORE
COMMON EVEN THOUSANDS OF POUNDS
WITHOUT POWER- I'M THE WITHOUT A
PENALTY BY NOT RELYING ON THE
GRAD AND CAN POWER AND KEEP KEEP
THE POWER ON EVEN DURING THE- AS
COMMUNITY THREE FAILED. THE
STATE SHOULD BE INSURANCE THAT
HOMES ARE CLEAN STAY SAFE AND
RESILIENT. FOR THESE REASONS WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TEN
SEVENTY EIGHT AND ASK FOR AN
OUTSIDE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CONNECTS WITH WITNESS- I BELIEVE
WE HAVE KIM STONE. YES THANK YOU
CAN TONE IT DOWN ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION- IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO DISPEL
ALL. ROOFTOP SOLAR- IS A GOOD
THING FOR CALIFORNIA IT HELPS
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE IT PROVIDES
RESIDENTS RELIEF FROM HIGH
ENERGY BILLS AND MAKE THAT HOME
AND IN FACT THE ENTIRE COMMITTEE
LAST BUT THAT PROVOKED FEW POWER
SHUT OFF. IT READ THE GRADE FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND NATURAL
GAS REBUILDING. SINCE THAT NEW
HOMES- ENDATE BECAME EFFECTIVE
IN JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY
BOWLER HAS BECOME THE STANDARD
ON NEW HOMES AS WALL
INSTALLATION. AND AFTER
SEPARATING THE REAL AT NINE ONE
AM TONIGHT THEN YOU KNOW TRAGEDY
OF LOSING YUR HOME THERE ARE A
WHOLE HOST OF- NEED A BUILDING
UPGRADES THAT- YOU KNOW THOSE
HOMEOWNERS LOOKING TO- TO FOLLOW
AND THIS BILL ONLY- EXAM FIRST
SINGLES OUT AT FULL ARE NONE OF.
NONE OF THE REST OF THE TOP RATE
THAN REALLY WHAT WE SHOULD BE
GIVING CALIFORNIA IS INCREASING.
OUR COMMITMENT AT THE LARK- WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT BUILDINGS
DON'T CONTRIBUTE TO GLOBAL BANK.
AND BANK HOMES BUILT IN THE
AFTERMATH OF A WILD MY FIRE ARE
IN SCREEN AS POSSIBLE AND AT
LEAST SEVEN FIREMEN ONLY
FRIENDLY IF NOT MORE SO THAN-
OTHER PHONE BILLS IN THE STATE.
WE NEED TO- MAKE SURE THAT WE
REDUCE OUR GREENHOUSE GAS.
EMISSIONS BILLION FORWARD THAT
WE NEED OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION GOALS AND THAT WE
PROVIDE. THE RESILIENCY THAT
CLEAN AND THE CLEAN ENERGY THAT
APPROVED THE WIRE PROVIDE. ALSO
I'M A LITTLE BIT INEQUITABLE
HOLDEN MANDATE. APPLIES TO-
APART. OF STORIES ARE LAST AND
SO IT WASN'T BILL. THAT BURNED
ON THE PARKING BUILDING WAS
REBUILT. AB APARTMENT WHICH IS.
HELLO ON. AND THOSE FUTURE
TENANTS IT WOULDN'T GET THE-
MONTHLY SAVING ADVANTAGES BUT
STILL ARE WE ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THEM READ PROPOSED
DIVISION. IN THE PDP AND-
FIGHTING. MIGHT LEAD TO YOU KNOW
CHANGE THAT SO THAT ROOFTOP
SOLAR CONTINUES TO BE ABSENT YOU
KNOW A VIABLE ECONOMIC.
ALTERNATIVE AND IN THE MEANTIME
BUT NOT. RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
THIS BILL AND- JOURNAL ABOUT.
THANK YOU I'M NEXT MOVE TO. OF
ADDITIONAL. ARE THERE ANY IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEE NON OPERATOR
Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB TEN SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE JUST STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
A BEACH TEN SEVENTY EIGHT. WHAT
IS DETERMINE IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK TO THIS BILL IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
PRESS ONE ZERO. WE'LL TAKE A
COMMENT FROM THE LINE OF LINE
SIXTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS WITH THE
VICTORIA ROME WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB TEN
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT FOR OUR NEXT COMMENT. NOW
HERE FROM ONE SEVENTY FIVE. YES
I'M HERE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
HI- MY NAME ISN'T ON YOUR
BRADFORD AND I ACTUALLY LOST MY
HOME EDC'S HE FIRED BACK IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY. WHEN I
AM CALLING TO URGE YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. I'VE DONE AT A
TIME BUT ONLY TV IN OUR
VICTIMIZATION ON THE BILL- WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD FROM WELL THEN I
SUPPORT IT THANK YOU. THERE ARE
NO OTHER COMMENTS PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU I'M NEXT ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. C.
NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE UP
THE FIRST OF ALL JUST TO REMIND
THAT THIS IS A- THIS IS A ONE
YEAR EXTENSION. THAT WE ARE
DOING FOR THOSE WHO BECAME
VICTIMS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
FIRE DISASTERS TO BE A FAIRLY
TREATED AS IF THOSE WHO WERE
WERE AT. TREATED WITH THE
EXEMPTION IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
AND THAT WE NEED TO BE FRANKLY
SEEING THESE INDIVIDUALS NOT AS
- PRUDENTIAL CUSTOMERS BUT AS
VICTIMS WHO NEED A RESPITE FROM
COSTS SO THAT THEY CAN. DO THAT
NOW. THAT WE CAN THAT WE CAN
HELP THEM IN TWENTY TWENTY AS AS
WE DID IN TWENTY NINETEEN IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT'S THE FAIR
THING TO DO. ASK YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- SO WE HAVE
A MOTION FOR MISTER MATHIS
SECONDED BY MR FLORA THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS RIVAS HI RIVAS
I FLOOR. FLOOR AYE BENNETT AYE
BENNETT AYE GARCIA. MATHIS FIVE
MATHIS I MCCARTY VOTING WHERE TO
CHECK NOT BUT- REYES NOT BOTH.
ZERO STONE STONE I WOULD. WOOD I. THE BILL HAS SIX VOTES WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN THANK YOU FOR THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU. I DON'T. YEAH
ONE WORKER- HELLO MR STONE IS
PRESENTING STRIPPING THIS BILL
AND- LOOKING. OKAY SO WELCOME OF
GO AHEAD AND MOVE UP I'M SINCE
OTHER AUTHORS ARE NOT IN THE
REHEARING ROOM- WILL- MOVED TO
MISTER BENNETT'S BILL SINCE HE
IS HERE. WELL THANK THAT. PLEASE
GO AHEAD AND- WHEN YOU'RE READY. YOU OF. I WASN'T EXPECTING TO
BE JUMPED ON SO SOONER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- BUT FIRST A MONSTER
BACK SECOND COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
MADAM CHAIR YOUR STAFF FOR
TAKING TIME OVER THE BREAK TO
HELP IMPROVE THE BILL- AND YOUR
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY NINE MAKES MODIFICATIONS
TO THE STATE'S EXISTING BY CLEAN
PROGRAM BY ADDING JEPSON
INSULATION CEILING TILES CARPET
CARPET TILES TO THE LIST OF
TURTLES. FOR WHICH DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES MUST DEVELOP
MAXIMUM ACCEPTABLE GLOBAL
WARMING POTENTIAL WINNERS
FINALLY WITH TODAY'S AMENDMENTS
THIS BILL WILL MAKE CLEAR THAT
THE MATERIALS ADDED SHALL BE
EVALUATED BASED ON PRODUCT
SPECIFIC GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL THIS CHANGE IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE MATERIALS
THIS BILL ADDS ARE OFTEN MADE BY
A SINGLE MANUFACTURER WHO CAN
MORE EASILY AND ACCURATELY
REPORT ALL NECESSARY
INFORMATION. AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
NINE TAKES AN IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD IN STRENGTHENING OUR BY
CLEAN PROGRAM SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE PROGRESS TOWARDS HARD
MISSIONS COLES AND MINIMIZE OUR
CARBON FOOTPRINT WITH EVERY
STATE FUNDED PROJECT ON THE
PHONE TODAY TO TESTIFY IS IN
SUPPORT OF DANIEL PRIDE OF THE
SIERRA CLUB AND JORDAN WELLS
FROM THE NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL. THANKFULLY AFTER
ARRIVAL THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT
I'M READY FOR WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT WILL START WITH DANIEL
BROUGHT. FOR THE SIERRA CLUB.
OPERATOR CAN PLEASE. MR BROUGHT
ON LINE. MISTER PRICELINE'S
ORDEAL BAKER. THAT GREAT ADD A
BROAD ON BEHALF OF THEIR CLUB
CALIFORNIA EXCITED TO BE HERE-
SUPPORTING ABOUT TODAY AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY NINE WHICH WOULD EXPAND
THE BY CRANE CALIFORNIA ACT AND
COMMON SENSE AND POOR WASTE.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE SPENDING AT
THE PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE
DOLLARS IN A MANNER THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH ITS NECESSARILY
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS. THEIR
CLUB CALIFORNIA WITH A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THE BY QUEEN
CALIFORNIA ACT WHEN IT WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW FIVE YEARS AGO.
WITH INNOVATIVE LAW REQUIRED THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
TO ESTABLISH A MALL MAXIMUM
GLOBAL WARMING POTENTIAL. FOR A
LIMITED LAST COMMENT
CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS THAT THE
STATE PREPARES FOR PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS. AB THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE
FELL DOWN THE BIKE LANE FOR AND
MARK AND EXPAND TO BUY CLEAN
CALIFORNIA ACT BY ADDING A SMALL
SET OF INTERIOR PRODUCTS. WHERE
THERE IS HIGH POTENTIAL. OF
CARBON REDUCTION AND PAVE THE
WAY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES TO ADD ELIGIBLE
MATERIAL I'D GET AS DATA BECOMES%
AVAILABLE AND MORE PRODUCT AND
MATERIAL CATEGORY. BY CRANE WAS
ALWAYS INTENDED TO INCLUDE MORE
PRODUCTS I MERGING TOOLS ARE
MAKING GATHERING THE- DATA
NECESSARY FOR THE BY CLEAN
PROGRAM EASIER FOR BOTH
MANUFACTURERS AND THE STATE.
THUS DISPEL IT IS SENSIBLE NEXT
STEP IN ADDRESSING CARBON
EMISSIONS AND CALIFORNIA'S
DEPARTURE. THIS IS A GOOD CELL
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT TO MAKE
IT BETTER AND CHAIR CLUB
CALIFORNIA TO COURT A. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE AND ASK FOR
YOUR I. ABOUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU I'M NEXT WE'RE
READY FOR JORDAN WELLS FROM THE
NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS I AM VERY
INVOLVED WITH THE NATIONAL
SEARCH OF ACTION COUNCIL A
NONPROFIT THAT ADVOCATES FOR
CIRCULAR AND EQUITABLE ECONOMY.
WE TALK ABOUT VOTING WITH THEIR
DOLLARS AT THE MOST IMPACTFUL
WAY TO SEND MARKET SIGNALS TO
PRODUCERS TO REDUCE NEGATIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIAL IMPACT
OF THEIR PRODUCTS AND PACKAGING.
WE BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT THE
STATE HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO
WALK THE TALK WHEN SETTING AND
IT. THAT IS WHY WE SUPPORTED THE
BY THING CALIFORNIA ACT SIGNED
INTO LAW IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WHICH CREATED A PROCESS FOR THE
STATE TO PROCURE SUSTAINABLE.
AND LOW CARBON CONSTRUCTION
MATERIALS. UNFORTUNATELY
INTERIOR MATERIALS SUCH AS
CARPET GYPSUM BOARD INFLATION
FEELING HELPLESS ADDRESS. OR NOT
ADDRESS AND CAN HAVE. A
SIGNIFICANT EFFECT ON CRIME THAT
. AB THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE WILL
FIX THE COMMISSION AND REQUIRE
CALIFORNIA TO VOTE WITH THEIR
DOLLARS BY DANCING BY CLEAN
APPROACH FOR INTERIOR
CONSTRUCTION MATERIAL. THE
CARBON DIOXIDE EMITTED DURING
THE EXTRACTION MANUFACTURE
TRANSPORT AND CONSTRUCTION
BUILDING MATERIALS IS
RESPONSIBLE 440% OF GLOBAL CO
TWO EMISSIONS. WE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND URGED THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO SUPPORT THE
FELT THANK YOU. THANK YOU- WE
DON'T HAVE ANY REGISTERED
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. BOB THE
WHOLE TO WE WILL ALL JUST GO
AHEAD AND FINISH THIS ONE SO WE
WILL- ANY WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. C. NINE- OPERATOR
Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AND THE THIRD ABOUT
ANYONE SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. WILL OPEN UP LINE SEVENTY
EIGHT GO AHEAD. DISPLACED PERSON
FROM THE TUBBS FIRE AND YOU MAKE
THIS IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE PUBLIC
TO PARTICIPATE YOU DO NOT FOLLOW
MEMBER ABOUT FOR YOU DISSIPATION
. AND IF THERE IS ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS LIKE TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL. SCENE NINE. THE CHAIR DOES
HAVE. A DO PASS- AS A MEMBER TO
APPROPRIATIONS MISTER BIN WHICH
I CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR RIVAL. WITH MOTIONS HI WE
GOT MOTIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH
ABSOLUTELY CULTURAL. THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS RIVAS FLORIDA
NO FLOOR NO BENNETT. HI BENNETT
I GARCIA GARCIA I MATHIS.
MCCARTY HI MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I. REYES.
REYES I SAY YADA STONE STONE I
WOULD. WHAT THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. BILL HAS SEVEN BUT
LEAVE IT OPEN. AND JUST ONE
MOMENT. LOOKING FOR AN AUTHOR.
CHRISTINE MISTER SEA. OF THEIR
AVAILABLE. SO WE WERE GARCIA
PRESENTING A. B. TEN OH ONE.
THANK YOU- ALSO OUT OF PRACTICE
- I APPRECIATE EVERYONE- AB ONE
OH ONE IS ABOUT PROTECTING
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES FROM
NEGATIVE AIR AND WATER AND PACKS
I LIVE IN ONE OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES IN THE CITY OF ALL
OF OUR AND THAT'S WHERE I GREW
UP WHERE I LIVE NOW. AND I TALK
ABOUT THAT PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
ALL THE TIME- I'M SURE YOU.
YOU'VE HAD ENOUGH OF IT
SOMETIMES. BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT WHAT WE'VE DONE SOME
PROGRESS HERE IN THE STATE
THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE DONE.
OUT THERE. ARE THESE COMMUNITIES
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
BY CANCER DIABETES ASTHMA
OFTENTIMES CALLED THINGS LIKE
CANCER ALLEY. AND THEY'VE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC AS WELL. THIS BILL
SIX INSURE THAT MITIGATION FOR
PROJECT HAPPENS DIRECTLY IN THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY AND NOT
SOMEWHERE ELSE IN THE STATE OR
THE WORLD. THE BILL ALSO SEEKS
TO ENSURE THAT AGENCIES
IMPLEMENTING PEOPLE ARE FALLING
PRINCIPLES. OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. I RECOGNIZE THAT MUCH
OF THE SEQUEL MITIGATION HAPPENS
WITHIN THE AFFECT THE COMMUNITY
BUT THAT IS NOT ALWAYS THE CASE.
SOME EXAMPLES INCLUDE TO GHG
REDUCTION PROJECTS THAT COULD BE
IN ANOTHER PART OF THE WORLD.
ARE POLLUTION MITIGATION THAT
MAY HAPPEN ELSEWHERE IN THE
REGION. MY CONCERN IS FOR THOSE
WHO ARE NEIGHBORS. WHAT ABOUT
THEIR HEALTH I OFTENTIMES
COMMITTEES LIKE MINOR TREE LIKE
WHERE SACRIFICE SO THERE IS
STILL DOUBLE FOR THE PROGRESS OF
OTHERS AND SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IF WE CAN THAT WE DO
ALL WE CAN TO MITIGATE WITHIN
THOSE COMMUNITIES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND IT DOES NOT LOOK
LIKE ANY REGISTER SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. SO WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES.
THAT I HAVE. I DON'T HAVE ANY ON
THE LIST- FULLER YES. MISTER
ROBERT PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR
SUPPORT. CHRIS JARVIS ON AB TEN
OH ONE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBER TODD MY NAME IS
CHRIS SHOPPERS THAT I AM THE
DEPUTY POLICY DIRECTOR COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR I'VE ALSO A WEST
LONG BEACH RESIDENT AND MEMBER
OF THE WILMINGTON CARSON IN WEST
PALM BEACH EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITY STEERING COMMITTEE.
CULTURE FOR CLEANER STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB ONE THOUSAND ONE THIS
BILL BENTON COMPARTMENTAL
JUSTICE BY ENSURING SPEAK WITH
MITIGATION REGIMENT HAVE A
DIRECT BENEFIT TO THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THIS
BILL WOULD ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
SHE COULD LEAD AGENCIES HAVE ACT
CONSISTENTLY OF COMPARTMENTAL
JUSTICE PRINCIPLES. HOW CLIMATE
. LEADERSHIP WHILE ADMIRABLE IS
NOT PROTECTED COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
MANY COMEDIANS PARTICULARLY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO
SUFFER A DESPERATE IMPACT. FOR
EXAMPLE THE WESTERN PART OF LONG
BEACH WHERE I LIVE AT HIGHER
RATES OF ASTHMA A HIGHER RISK OF
CANCER AND ULTIMATELY A SHORTER
LIFE EXPECTANCY THAN THE EASTERN
PART OF THE- THIS ISN'T
SURPRISING GIVEN THAT TWO OF THE
WORLD'S MOST SIGNIFICANT
SEAPORTS ARE ALSO IN NEARBY.
ALONG WITH LOCAL RAIL YARDS AND
FREEWAYS THE BULK OF CALIFORNIA
OIL REFINING CAPACITY AND
THOUSANDS OF ACTIVE AND INACTIVE
OIL DRILLING SITES. BUT WHAT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT THESE
POLLUTION SOURCES ARE HERE
BECAUSE OF CHOICES BOTH BY THE
INDUSTRY TO END UP WITH A FOCUS
PROJECTS. ALONG WITH HE
AGENCIES APPROVAL. A DIFFICULT
CHOICE BEN PUTTING POLLUTION
SORTS OF AN OVERBURDENED
COMMUNITIES REMAINS A CHOICE
THAT. WE HAVE THE TOOLS TO HELP
POLICYMAKERS MAKE INFORMED
CHOICES. FECAL AND OTHER LAWS
NOT ONLY REQUIRE AGENCIES TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACTS OF
APPROVING A NEW PROJECT BUT CAN
ALSO REDUCE OR ELIMINATE
POLLUTION THE FIRST PLACE.
IDEALLY THIS SHOULD MEAN THAT
ANY HARM TO THE COMMUNITY THAT
THEY MIGHT EXPERIENCE DUE TO A
PROJECT CAN BE DISSIPATED AND
MITIGATE. YES TO THE PURCHASING
OF CREDITS AND OTHER COMPLIANCE
PATHWAYS THAT MEDICATION
MEASUREMENTS CAN BE IMPLEMENTED
OUTSIDE THE COMMUNITY WHERE THE
PROJECT IS LOCATED. WITH ITS
FINANCIALLY EXPORTS THE BENEFITS
OF A PROJECT OUT OF THE
COMMUNITY WHILE CONCENTRATING
ITS ADVERSE IMPACTS WITH THAT.
FURTHER AGENCIES ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO CONSIDER
ENVIRONMENTAL AID IT BY MAIL
JOHNSON WOULD MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT POLLUTING FACILITIES. NO
WHERE IS THIS MORE EVIDENT WITH
THEM WITH CALIFORNIA'S MAIN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE TOOL
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN. AMONG
OTHER THINGS EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN REQUIRED THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AND AIR DISTRICTS TO IDENTIFY
AND WORK WITH INVITE HIGHLY
ENVIRONMENTALLY BURDEN
COMMUNITIES. DEVELOP EMISSION
REDUCTIONS OF MODERN PLANS. YET
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AD STATE
AGENCIES ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
CONSIDER EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
PLANS. AS A RESULT NEW POLLUTING
INDUSTRIES CONTINUE TO BE
APPROVED. IN AND AROUND OVER
BURDEN COMMUNITIES. EIGHTY ONE
THOUSAND ONE CORRECT THESE
DEFICIENCIES BY REQUIRING
MITIGATION MEASUREMENTS THAT
DIRECTLY BENEFIT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. IN OTHER WORDS IF
YOU'RE GOING TO COLLUDED
COMMUNITY EFFORTS TO ELIMINATE
THAT POLLUTION NEED TO BENEFIT
THOSE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING THE
VOTE TO BE THINKING AT THE MOST.
LIKEWISE AB ONE THOUSAND ONE
WOULD REQUIRE AGENCIES TO
CONSIDER ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
WHILE CONSIDERING NEW PROJECTS.
LASTLY IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THIS PROJECT WOULD NOT
PREDETERMINE THE OUTCOME OF
LOCAL DECISION MAKING RATHER IS
JUST MAKING SURE. THAT WE DO NOT
WITH THAT WE DO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY NOT CONTINUE
CHOOSING TO CONCENTRATE
POLLUTION IN OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH. NOW WE
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION ON AB TO
THE ONE WE GOTTA ADAM REGAL FROM
CAL CHAMBER AND STILL BE FAR
FROM THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING-
WELL CBI. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ADAMANTLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION. I WANT TO BEGIN
BY CREDITING THE AUTHOR FOR HER
STEADFAST COMMITMENT TO READING
HISTORICAL ENVIRONMENTAL AND GOT
IT IN OUR COMMUNITY. I WANT TO
BE CLEAR OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL IS NOT WITH THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY.
BUT WITH A PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
SEAT BUT TO OVERLAY NEW AND
HIGHLY SUBJECTIVE STANDARD NOT
ONLY AGENCIES. AND TO LIMIT
THEIR DISCRETION. HE WAS AN
EXTRAORDINARILY COMPLEX AND ALL
ENCOMPASSING ENVIRONMENTAL LAW
WITH A MULTITUDE OF SUBSTANTIVE
AND PROCEDURAL REQUIREMENT
INTENDED TO ANALYZE. QUANTIFY
DISCLOSE AND MITIGATE THE
PROJECT CAN IMPACT WORKABLE.
THIS BILL OVERLAYS NEW STANDARDS
ABOUT WHAT IS QUOTE FAIR OR
QUOTE MEANINGFUL PARTICIPATION
OVER EVERY FINDING UNDER SEEK
WHAT. THAT PROVIDE PROJECT
OPPONENTS WITH NEW LITIGATION
AVENUES UNDER AN APARTMENT
STATUTE ALREADY. RIFE WITH NAME
THE ABUSE. THE BILL WHARTON
STATE HOUSING WHEN HOME PRICE
ARE EIGHT FEET EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND RENT IT AT
ALL TIME HIGHS. SECOND THERE ARE
EXISTING LAWS WHICH ALREADY
ACHIEVED THE BILL'S INTENT TO
ADDRESS LAND USE DISCRIMINATION
IN CALIFORNIA AND DO SO WITHOUT
EXACERBATING KNOWN PROBLEMS WITH
EQUAL. LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN SB ONE THOUSAND
THAT REQUIRED EVERY FEEDING
COUNTY TO INCORPORATE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IN A
COMPREHENSIVE LONG TERM GENERAL
PLAN. AN OPR JUST RECENTLY
RELEASED GUIDELINES IN TWENTY
TWENTY PROVIDING MORE SPECIFIC
ON HOW CITIES AND COUNTIES
SHOULD IDENTIFY OBJECTIVES AND
POLICIES TO REDUCE HELP TO
REDUCE HEALTH RISKS IN A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY. IT'S
UNCLEAR TO WHAT AB ONE THOUSAND
ONE INTENT TO ADDRESS. AT EIGHT
THAT THE ONE THOUSAND FAILED TO
DO. FINALLY AB ONE THOUSAND
LIMITATION ON MEDICATION
MEASURES ARE IN DIRECT CONFLICT
WITH EXISTING PROVISIONS OF
SEQUEL SEQUEL AND LEAD TO
PERVERSE RESULTS. FOR EXAMPLE
THE VAST MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES DO NOT WATER.
CONSIDER THE GREAT LIFE AND
COUNTY THEY DERIVE THE MAJORITY
OF THE WATER THE STATE WATER
PROJECT. THE COLORADO RIVER IN A
LOS ANGELES AQUEDUCT. HUNDREDS
OF MILES TO RESIDENTS. IN OTHER
WORDS MOST RESIDENTS ARE NOT
SOURCE IN OUR WATER DIRECTLY
BENEATH THEIR FEET. AB ONE
THOUSAND ONE WITH THE JEFF THAT
ANY PROJECT THAT COULD IMPACT
THAT IS THE BEST NEEDED WATER
SUPPLY. MUCH TO DO SO IN THAT
COMMUNITY RATHER THAN MITIGATING
THE IMPACT OF THE STORE WHERE
THE POLLUTION MICHAEL POLLUTING
THEIR WATER HUNDREDS OF MILES
AWAY. THIS CHANGES HE WOULD
ACTUALLY WORK FOR ALL RESIDENTS
INCLUDING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. FORTY THREE THAN
THAN OTHERS WE URGE A NO VOTE ON
EXPANDING PECORA AND REMAIN
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION. TO FURTHER
SUPPORT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
IN MORE APPROPRIATE AREAS OF LAW
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN WILL BE
OVER HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION ALSO UNFORTUNATELY
IN OPPOSITION AT A AS YOU JUST
HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
CHAMBER AB TEN ZERO ONE
CONTEMPLATES A TRULY SIGNIFICANT
EXPANSION SPEAK UP. THIS BILL IS
GIVING THE DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY
A GREAT DEAL OF CONCERN NOT
BECAUSE OF THE POLICY OBJECTIVE
I WAS JUST OUTLINED BY MY
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES NOT BECAUSE
OF THE TOOL OF CHOICE TO
EFFECTUATE THE DESIRED POLICY
YEAR AFTER YEAR WE HAVE SEEN
ATTEMPTS WE HAVE HEARD THE
GROWING DISCUSSION IN THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT WAYS. TO CLOSE
THE EVER WORSENING ABUSIVE
SEQUEL FOR NON ENVIRONMENTAL
REASONS BUT UNFORTUNATELY TO NO
AVAIL AND THEREFORE THIS
LEGISLATURE AND MANY BEFORE IT
HAVE CONTINUED TO VOTE FOR THE
QUICK EXEMPTIONS FOR SPEAK WITH
STREAMLINING FOR PET PROJECT
AFTER PET PROJECT. AND UNTIL WE
ADDRESS THE ABUSE OF SECRET FOR
ALL HOUSING TYPES WHICH AS YOU
KNOW IS MORE EXPENSIVE AND MORE
OUT OF REACH BY THAT DAY AND
GROWING FOR EVERY CALIFORNIANS
WE ABSOLUTELY SHOULD NOT BE
CONSIDERING EXPANSION. THE BILL
IS LITIGATION BANK IT'S A BIG U.
S. AND THAT IS RIGHT AT THE
HEART OF SEQUEL ABUSE THIS WILL
BE ANOTHER NAME BE TOOL AT HIGH
HOUSING PROJECTS INTO THE COURT
AN ATTEMPT TO STALL THEM OR EVEN
WORSE RENDERED THOSE PROJECTS IN
FEASIBLE. WE ALSO HAVE PROVEN IT
THROUGH OTHER POLICIES WE'VE
GOTTEN IT. DONE AND ROLLED OUR
SLEEVES UP. WE ARE HAPPY WORK ON
THIS ISSUE WE BELIEVE THAT THE-
INTENT DESIRE AB. AWARDING BUT
THIS TIME WE WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
KNOW ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MODERATE TO HAVE ANY
BUT ONE ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AND
FROM THE TELEPHONE LINES IF YOU
ARE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WILL FIRST GO TO
LINE SEVENTY GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THE MEMBERS THAT DID SUPPORT
MANAGER WITH THE CLIMATE CENTER
IN A SUPPORT AND CONCEPT
OPPOSITION FOR AB ONE THOUSAND
ONE BUT THE COURTS WORKING WITH
THE OPPORTUNITY TO. SELL IMPROVE
THANK YOU. WILL MOVE NEXT TO
LINE SIXTY FIVE GO AHEAD. NINE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
BELIEVE THAT TO ME THAT'S THE
VICTORIA ROME WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ALSO
IN SUPPORT. WE WILL MOVE NEXT TO
LINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU TO SHARE
MEMBERS JOHN LINGER ON THE UP
FOR THE CALIFORNIA FUELS AND
CONVENIENCE Y. AND AN UPDATE.
LINE EIGHTY ONE. NINE EIGHTY ONE
IS THAT ME. YES. REALLY HE'S
MOVING ON TO LINE SIXTY SEVEN GO
RUSSIAN THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
FIND. SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CODY BOILED
IN BEHALF OF THE WESTERN ACT
PROCESSORS THAT STATION AND THE
AMERICAN STATURE GROWTH IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. EIGHTY
TWO. MADDIE MONTHS SPENT ON
BEHALF OF THE AGRICULTURAL
ENERGY CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION AND
OPPOSITION. NINE FIFTY FOUR. BUT
LOWER YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD
. THIS IS EVER MADISON FROM THE
APARTMENT CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. LINE
EIGHTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS GAIL TELECAST WITH
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY FOUR. EXACTLY WHAT THE
ONCE YOU TAKE CONTROL THE
PETITION FOR POST. PINE SEVENTY
SIX. AND SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
SIXTY FOUR GO AHEAD PLEASE. NINE
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TO
MOVE BONTA LINE THIRTY FIVE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD EVENING
MEMBERS ROB SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE OTHER
LINE QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT WHILE
WE PROVIDE THEM THEIR LINE
NUMBER. I WE'LL GO TO ONCE AGAIN
TO LINE EIGHTY FOUR GO AHEAD
PLEASE. WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
ACTUALLY SHOW UP TO WORK SO YOU
CAN CONDUCT THIS HEARING IN A
PUBLIC LIBRARY NANOGRAMS BECAUSE
THIS IS A SHAM NEXT CALL WE WILL
MOVE TO LINE SIX. SIXTY FOUR. HI
GOOD EVENING THE GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT THE DELHI GOVERNMENT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. NINE SEVENTY SIX UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE YES BY SEVENTY SIX GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THIS IS NOT THE
HARD OVER THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
ASSOCIATING HERSELF WITH THE
CALCHAMBER AND B. I. EIGHT
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU NEXT ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I MISS REYES. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MS GARCIA FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I THINK
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND MAKING
SURE THAT THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE MOST IMPACTED ARE THE ONES
THAT RECEIVE THE BENEFIT I THINK
THAT IT IS AND I THINK EVEN THE
OPPOSITION THEY SAID THE INTENT
IS A WORTHY ONE AND I
APPRECIATED THEIR COMMENT ON
THAT ONE OF THE MEMBERS- ALSO
TALKED SAID THAT THERE WERE SOME
AMBIGUITIES IN THE PROPOSED
LEGISLATION. I'D CERTAINLY ANY
AMBIGUITY I WOULD HOPE THAT
WOULD BE TAKEN CARE OF BUT I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND WITH THAT I WOULD
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU ARE
MISTER BENNETT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF. FIRST I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS- EFFORTS
WITH THIS BILL IN THE FOCUS-
AND- I ALSO AS I LISTEN TO SOME
OF THE COMMENTS AND I. THE
COMMENT THAT YOU WOULD HAVE TO
TREAT THE WATER AT THE SOURCE-
DID DID THAT MAKE SENSE TO ME IS
IN THAT IF YOU HAVE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT IN THE
COMMUNITY. YOU WHAT THE POINT IS
YOU WANT TO FIX THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT IF YOU HAVE
TO TREAT THE WATER AT THE SOURCE
TO FIX ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT THAT
FIXES THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
OF- I DIDN'T THINK THAT WAS A
GOOD EXAMPLE BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK THE AUTHOR- AS- AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD I THINK THIS IS A VERY
WORTHY BILL. I JUST WANTED TO BE
A GREAT BILL IN TERMS OF BEING
ACTUALLY PRACTICAL IN ITS
IMPLEMENTATION AND COMING FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND THE THINGS
THAT I SEE THERE. I JUST HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER THAT'S
THE CASE AND I AM- PINCH HITTING
ON THIS COMMITTEE SO IT'S NOT
LIKE I'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
WITH THIS BILL I JUST WOULD ASK
THE AUTHOR HAS THIS MOVES
FORWARD- TO KEEP WORKING TO
ADDRESS THE TRUE. PRACTICAL
IMPLEMENT IMPLICATIONS OF THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT IS A SIGNIFICANT
AND WORTHY EXPANSION BUT IF IT'S
NOT PRACTICAL IN ITS
IMPLEMENTATION- AND AS WE COME
UP WITH ANYTHING ELSE I'LL
CERTAINLY TRY TO OFFER THOSE TO
YOU BUT IF. FROM A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT STANDPOINT IT WON'T
ALWAYS BE EASY I'LL JUST. GIVE
YOU A ONE ONE THAT DOES
STRICTLY. ONE HOW HOW LOCAL DOES
THE MEDICATION HAVE TO BE HOW
SPECIFIC WHERE DO YOU DRAW THE
BOUNDARIES TO ARE THE- ARE THE
DACA BOUNDARIES THE ONLY
BOUNDARIES WERE TALKING ABOUT
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT. ALL LOCAL
AREAS WHERE YOU HAVE AN IMPACT
IF YOU COULD JUST MAKE SURE YOU
TIGHTEN ALL OF THAT UP SO IT'S
CLEAR AND YOU DON'T HAVE
CONFLICTS WITH OTHER PARTS OF
SEQUEL. IT WILL MAKE IT- MORE
CREDIBLE AS YOU GO FORWARD BUT I
HOPE TO SEE. MORE OF THAT IN THE
BILL AND I'M SUPPORTING THIS
BECAUSE I WANTED. TO GO FORWARD
AND IN IN GET THAT RIGOROUS
REVIEW THAT- THAT IT WILL GET AS
IT MOVES ITS WAY TO THE
LEGISLATURE SO. SURELY BE
SUPPORTING IT BUT I APPRECIATE
BEING ABLE TO MAKE THESE
COMMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER MOORE SEARCHING. THANK
YOU I ALSO LIKE MR BENNETT TO.
SUPPORT THE GOAL OF THIS BUILD-
BUT I HAVE A- CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
IT WOULD ACTUALLY BE- R. HOW CAN
BE TIGHTENED UP TO. ADDRESS SOME
OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION HI I WANT TO ASK YOU-
MS GARCIA GUY IF YOU COULD
RESPOND TO. THE CONCERN ABOUT
YOU KNOW HOW HOW WOULD HOW WOULD
YOU MITIGATE THE IMPACT-
DIRECTLY AND EFFECTIVE COMMUNITY
WHEN THEY'RE DEALING WITH THE
CONSEQUENCES OF SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED UPSTREAM. IN ANY CASE
WATER. TWO THINGS- I THINK IF
SOMETHING'S HAPPENING UP STREAM
IT WOULD BE DEALT WITH UP THERE
AND SO WE WOULDN'T HAVE THE
PROBLEM AND THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY. I COMMUNITY GETS A
LOT OF THEIR GROUNDWATER A LOT
OF THE WATER FROM GROUNDWATER-
AND A LOT OF THE POLLUTION
THAT'S HAPPENING THERE IS
ACTUALLY MAKING IT TO THE WE'RE
HAVING TO TURN OFF WEALTH AND
IMPORT- MORE WATER WHICH IS MUCH
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN A
SUSTAINABLE OUT THERE. I THINK
THERE I'VE BEEN HERE THIS IS MY
TENTH YEAR. I AND GETTING FOLKS
ON BOARD ON THE CONCEPT AND TO
COME TO THE TABLE YOU FIX A
LITTLE BIT OF WORK ON THIS. SO
WHAT I'VE BEEN ASKING MYSELF THE
WHOLE TIME I'VE BEEN HERE IS ARE
WE GOING TO KEEP TELLING THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
THIS IS GOOD AS IT GETS. WE DO
HAVE SEEK WHEN THE BOOKS NOT IT
HAS IMPROVED SOMETHING FOR MY
COMMUNITY BUT HAS IMPROVED
ENOUGH IN MY COMMUNITY. I'M
STILL ONE OF THE MOST
OVERBURDENED COMMUNITIES I'M
PRETTY MUCH ANY AND IF YOU COULD
IMAGINE OUT THERE- AN SO HASN'T
BEEN ENOUGH AND WE ARE ALWAYS
TOLD. DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE CARE OF IT AND
THIS OTHER PART OF TOWN OR
SOMEPLACE SOUTH AND YOU JUST
DEAL WITH. THAT IF IT GETS FOR
YOU. SO ARE WE GONNA KEEP
TELLING THEM THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO BE THE SACRIFICE. BY PHONE
THEY ARE GOING TO BE AT THE COST
OF EVERYONE ELSE'S PROGRESS OUT
THERE IN THE YARD. HAVE TO BE
DISCUSSED AND FIGURED OUT AND I
WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE TABLE TO
HELP ME GET IT RIGHT I THINK MY
TEN YEAR. IN APAC MATIC AND I
TRY TO COMPROMISE AND OFTENTIMES
IS BIG LIVES AND UP IN THAT
COMPROMISED IF I BRING FOLKS TO
THE TABLE TO HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION FOR BILLS AND-
WAITING ONCE AND FOR ALL WE NEED
TO SAY WE'RE GOING TO TAKE CARE
OF THOSE COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
THE- LENGTH. HAVE BEEN THE BOTH
BURDEN AND THAT'S WHAT WE NEED
TO START IN THIS IS ONE BILL OF
MANY BILLS WE NEED IN THAT
COMMUNITY ALSO ONE MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S CLEAR THAT. IT'S NOT A
ONE AND DONE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. THE YOU KNOW THE
EXISTENCE OF HOW THIS SOCIETY
HAS BEEN AND HOW WE'VE
CONSTITUTED THIS COMMITTEE THIS
WEEK THIS WAY IT'S NOT JUST OVER
AND SO. I ALSO TO IT CLEAR THAT
TO WITH MANY MORE AFTER THIS
YEAR. I TO MY OF THE STATE AND
FIGHT YOU. I DO THANK MR IT'S
AND I WALKING INTO ME FOR OUT
HOW TO MAKE THE NETWORK AT THIS
. A LONG THE WAY AND ALL OF THE
TOGETHER CAN ACTUALLY. LOOK UP
TO. THAT WE LET. THE AND PUT.
TEETH INTO. OKAY I MEAN I ALSO.
WELL I- RECOGNIZE THAT THAT YOU
COMMUTER AND LA- DO- CARRIED
PORTION BURDEN OF- THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS BUT I'M
JUST ON THIS ISSUE OF- WATER
IMPACTS AND WHO DEALS WITH THE
CONSEQUENCES DOWNSTREAM I MEAN I
JUST WANT TO REMIND YOU THAT YOU
KNOW I. AS AS YOU KNOW I
REPRESENT A COASTAL DISTRICT
THAT- OFTEN COMPLAINS ABOUT HOW
YOU KNOW THE MIDDLE CLASS TO
AFFLUENT COMMUNITIES IN MY
DISTRICT THAT LIVE ON THE COAST
OFTEN COMPLAINED ABOUT HAVING TO
DEAL WITH THE WATER CLEAN UP
COSTS OF THE POLLUTION UPSTREAM
AND SO IT'S NOT JUST- THE- YOU
KNOW WHAT WHILE I APPRECIATE
YOUR FRAMING THIS BILL AS A
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE BILL- YOU
KNOW THERE THERE ARE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES THAT DEAL
WITH. THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS-
YOU KNOW WITH ESPECIALLY OF
WATER UPSTREAM AND IT'S NOT JUST
NECESSARILY THE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND SO I WOULD JUST
ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER THAT AS AS
YOU GO FOR THE OTHER CONCERN- IS
THAT IN A WHILE I TO- YOU KNOW-
PLAN ON VOTING FOR THIS BILL. A
TODAY. THAT YOU KNOW I. AS A
LAWYER I ALWAYS WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THAT WE CAN. TRY TO
TIGHTEN UP THE TERMS- SO THAT IT
IT'S A- WE CAN TRY TO AVOID- YOU
KNOW- LITIGATION ABUSE AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE AND I CAN SEE HOW.
YOU KNOW A TERM LIKE MANY
MEANINGFUL INVOLVEMENT OF A- OF
A COMMUNITY. THAT COULD BE RIPE
FOR ABUSE AND SO I HOPE YOU CAN.
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO TIGHTEN UP
THAT LANGUAGE ALSO THANK YOU.
WE'LL DEFINITELY KEEP WORKING ON
THAT AND I DON'T WNT TO DO A
DIFFERENT TACK BUT- FOLKS IN MY
FOR THE ROLE OF OFTEN FEELS LIKE
THEY'RE ALSO PAYING EXTRA TO
REPLENISH. THE GROUNDWATER IN
THE SCHOOLS THE COMMUNITIES- TO
MAKE SURE THAT. THAT FALL AND
FUSION YOU KNOW- THE SENATE
AFFECT ALL OF OUR TABLE WATER SO
IT IS ALL INTERCONNECTED. OUT
THERE AND SO I DON'T THINK IT'S
- AT. WORK CAN CONTINUE TO BE
DONE BUT- THERE'S BEEN PLENTY A
LAWSUIT FROM MY FINANCING THAT
WAY OF THE DAY SO THAT OTHERS
HAD A TON OF WATER AS WELL. CAN
MISTER FLORES THANK YOU MEASURE.
THANK YOU- I'M IS A LITTLE BIT
AWAY FROM WATER AND I DO IF IT'S
ALRIGHT WITH CHAIR WOULD LIKE
THE CHAMBER TO CLARIFY SOME OF
THEIR OPPOSITION AS RELATES TO
THAT. EXAMPLE I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO GET THAT
CLARIFICATION- IF ADAM COULD
EVER SO BRIEFLY- ADDRESS THAT.
BUT I DO WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THEIR REAL QUICK. AND BECAUSE IN
MY DISTRICT WE TEND TO DEAL WITH
A LOT OF THE BAY AREA ISSUES AS
WELL. AND SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE ONLY STEP DOWNSTREAM. IT IS
A VERY- IMPORTANT. QUESTION
BECAUSE ONE OF OUR OTHER MAJOR
ISSUES IN THE CENTRE DOLLARS
HOUSING. SO IF WE'RE EALING
WITH OUR PROBLEMS PLUS THE BAY
AREA PROBLEMS AND THAT CAN BE
USED TO. STALL IN HOUSE PROJECT
. IT IS A PROBLEMATIC SO THIS
IDEA THAT IT IS CONNECTED. IT'S
ABSOLUTELY CONNECTED AND I WOULD
JUST- ENCOURAGE US TO THINK
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE- THOUGH WE
MAY BE FIXING THE PROBLEM HERE
OR THERE. IT'S CREATING ANOTHER
ONE AND SO IF WE COULD JUST HAVE
ADAM JUST CLARIFY HIS REMARKS
AND- ALLEN JUST KEEP IT SHORT.
SURE PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU
BYE. THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR I
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT'S POINT THAT THE
AT THE MINIMUM TO CHECK THE
SPOKE TO IT BUT IN THE ACTUAL
BILL SAYS THE A FACT SHALL BE
MITIGATED DIRECTLY IN THE
AFFECTED DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES MY POINT ABOUT WATER
IS WE'RE NOT DRAWING WATER FROM
UNDERNEATH COMMUNITY. WHERE
PROJECT MAY ACTUALLY HAVE A
DISCHARGE YOU WANT TO GET IT AT
OF SORTS THAT WE HUNDRED A MILE
UPSTREAM FROM THE COMMUNITY
IMPACTED INFO AT POSTED ON THE
COMMITTEE THE LANGUAGE MATTERS
AND SO IF YOU REQUIRE THE
MITIGATION TO BE DIRECTLY IN
THAT COMMUNITY ARE NOT ACTUALLY
STOP IN A POINT OF DISCHARGE SO
IT ACTUALLY I THINK IT'S WORSE
AS AN ENVIRONMENTAL OUTCOME. THE
DO IT ACTION THAT WOULD MEAN
YOU'D HAVE TO. BUT THE PEOPLE
HAVE Y. CREATED NEW. APPLE
INTRICATE PLANT IN THE COMMUNITY
TO CLEAN WATER THAT WHAT I. DO
IN A MILE SOUTH THE PEOPLE
IDENTIFIES. THE IMPACT. AND IT
IT DIFFICULT THE MITIGATION TO
ADDRESS THAT. SO IT IT
ESSENTIALLY BEFORE YOU HAVE TO
START MITIGATING UNDER SPEAK
WHAT THE- SORRY IF THERE'S ANY
CONFUSION ABOUT THAT APPRECIATE
THE ATTEMPT TO CLARIFY THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS I DON'T SEE ANY. I'M
JUST A YOU KNOW THE FOR A LITTLE
BIT IT AT ME JUST IN THE
INTEREST OF TRYING TO CLARIFY
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
THIS I GUESS THIS IS MY
INTERPRETATION WE HAVE STAFF
HERE I JUST GET IT OUT THERE-
MAY NOT BE BACK HERE THE FACT
THAT- IF THERE'S AN
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT ON WATER OR
WHATEVER ERROR OR WHATEVER- IN A
IN A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY TO
WHAT MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE
INTENT OF THE BILL WOULD SAY. IF
PEOPLE ARE GETTING SICK BECAUSE
THE WATER IS BAD YOU'VE GOT TO
CHANGE THE WATERS OF THE PEOPLE
ARE GETTING SICK IF YOUR PROJECT
IS GOING TO MAKE THE PEOPLE SICK
NOW THAT MEANS YOU CHANGE WHAT
DOES DOESN'T MEAN YOU HAVE TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACT IN THAT
COMMUNITY BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
DO THE MITIGATION IN THAT
COMMUNITY IF YOU. HAVE TO CLEAN
UP THE AIR THAT IS YOU KNOW
ASSEMBLY IF YOU'RE DOING
SOMETHING IN A IN A IN A
COMMUNITY IF YOU'RE DOING
SOMETHING TO A PROJECT THAT IS
NOW- LET'S SEE YOU REMOVE SOME
KIND OF FILTER THAT ALLOWS NOW
DIRTY WATER TO GET IT YOU'VE GOT
TO GO WHEREVER IT IS YOU REMOVED
THAT FILTER TO MITIGATE THE
IMPACT ON THE COMMUNITY THAT'S
THE INTENTION I HOPE THAT THAT.
HELPS CLARIFY FOR THE CHAMBER OF
WHAT I WAS TRYING TO HAVE TO
RESPOND TO IN TERMS OF THAT I
DON'T THINK I JUST DON'T THINK
IT'S ACCURATE TO SAY THEY THEY
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO GO SOME
PLACE OUTSIDE OF THE COMMUNITY
IF THAT'S WHAT WILL SOLVE THE
IMPACT IN THE COMMUNITY BUT THE
POINT IS. DON'T GO OUTSIDE OF
THE COMMUNITY TO MAKE OR
SOMEPLACE ELSE AND YOU PAY FOR
THIS COMMUNITY TO CONTINUE TO BE
DISADVANTAGED I BELIEVE THAT'S
WHAT YOU ALSO TRYING TO DO WITH
THE BILL AND THAT'S AT LEAST
MINOR WAS THAT THE YOU MUCH.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSENESS GARCIA
UP I WILL TAKE MISTER AND IT'S-
A- STATEMENT AFFECT BOTH
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THAT WAS GREAT. THANK
YOU. SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE WITH HI. I FLOOR.
NO FLOOR NO BENEFIT. HI I GARCIA
HI GARCIA I MATHIS MCCARTY AYE
MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE RADIUS HI RES
ISENGARD OF NOW. ZERO NO STONE
STONE I WOULD WOOD HI. THE BILL
HAS EIGHT VOTE SOME OF EVEN OPEN
HER. ABSENT MEMBERS I'M WE HAVE
TO BILLS LEFT IN THIS HEARING-
AB TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN BY MR
LEVINE. I'M AND THE FINAL BILL
WILL BE AB TEN SIXTY SEVEN BY
MISTER TEAM FOR WILL BE
PRESENTED BY MR STONE- SO LET'S
GO AHEAD AND START WITH AB
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN HELLO THANK
YOU SO MUCH THEM MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS COULD IT BE WITH YOU AB
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN WOULD DIRECT
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. TO CONSIDER
AMENDMENTS TO THE ROOF
REPLACEMENT CENTERS FOR EXISTING
LOW RISE STEEP SLOPE RESIDENTIAL
BUILDINGS WITH THE GOAL OF
INCREASING. THE MINIMUM SOLAR
REFLECTANCE OF ROOFS OF DOUBLING
IT FROM. POINT TWO OH TWO POINT
FOR- AN EXPANDING NUMBER OF
CLIMAE ZONES WERE ENERGY
EFFICIENT ROOFS. ARE REQUIRED
ESSENTIALLY WE'RE CREATING HEAT
ISLANDS WITH REALLY HIGH
ROOFTOPS AND IF WE CAN MAKE COOL
ROOFS AS THEY'RE CALLED WE CAN
REDUCE TEMPERATURES INSIDE
BUILDINGS- BUYS MUCH ASIDE FIVE
TO TWENTY DEGREES DEPENDING ON
TIME OF DAY AND THAT THE HEAT ON
TOP OF THE BUILDINGS ON THE
ROOFS. BY AS MUCH AS FIFTY
DEGREES SO COOLING THE
TEMPERATURES IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES ACTUALLY SAVING
LIVES BECAUSE THERE IS AN ISSUE
WITH MORTALITY FROM HEAT ILLNESS
AS WELL I RESPECT THAT FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SECOND PLEASE. WAIT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY OF WITNESSES
REGISTERED IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION- SO I'LL GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
ANY AND THE HEARING ROOM SEE NON
OPERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR AB TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN
WE'RE TAKING OUR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE JUST STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THIS BILL. THIS WEEK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE AT THIS TIME. WILL OPEN UP
LINE EIGHTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE
. I WOULD WORK HIGHER THAT BY
EIGHTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THAT PARTIAL BECAUSE- WILL MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT CALLER ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE THEIR
LINE NUMBER. LIKE IF PLEASE
CLICK THE PURPLE. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WE DO HAVE ONE MORE IN Q.
WILL OPEN. MADAM CHAIR CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD-
THIS IS CHRIS BOLLINGER ON
BEHALF OF THE ASPHALT ROOFING
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION WE
WANT TO BE LISTED AS LEAD
OPPOSITION- CAN YOU AFFORD ME
JUST A MINUTE I'LL BE BRIEF.
YOU'LL PLEASE GO AHEAD JUST ONE
MINUTE- THE ASPHALT ROOFING
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION IS THE
TRADE ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
NORTH AMERICAN PRODUCERS OF-
PRODUCTS INCLUDING ASPHALT
SHINGLES ASPHALT LOW SLOPE. ROOF
MEMBRANE SYSTEMS IN THEIR RAW
MATERIAL SUPPLIERS WE'VE BEEN
OPPOSE POSITION ON AB TWELVE
TWENTY SEVEN FOR ALL THE REASONS
WE LAID OUT IN OUR LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE I'LL TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE OF THESE REASONS. THE CDC
ALREADY HAS THE STATE GOVERNMENT
APPROVED ROBUST CODE CODE
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS WHICH
CONSIDERS NEWLY DEVELOPMENT
NEWLY DEVELOPED AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGIES AND BY LAW UNDER
THE WARRANT ALQUIST ACT-CAUTIOUSLY CATION OUR INDUSTRIES
WORK DIRECTLY WITH THE
COMMISSION SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THREE POLICE FIRST BECAME A
TOPIC OF CONSIDERATION. WE
RESPONDED THE COMMISSION ENERGY
EFFICIENT TARGETS WITH MATERIALS
THAT PROVIDE VALUABLE LEGITIMATE
OPTIONS TO HOMEOWNERS. WHEN THEY
SEE YOU SEE SHOULD EXAMINE
BENEFITS OTHER EFFICIENT
BUILDING MATERIALS BEFORE
ADOPTING AN UNWIELDY BILL THAT
LIMITS CONSUMER CHOICE AND
IMPOSES SIGNIFICANT COSTS
BURDENS MOREOVER PRODUCT
AVAILABILITY REMAINS A CHALLENGE
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT. THEY'RE
CURRENTLY ZERO ASPHALT ROOFING
MATERIALS AND ZERO WOULD CHECK
MATERIALS THAT CAN MEET THE
THRESHOLD SET BY THIS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION WE KNOW IT'S EARLY
IN THE PROCESS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED- THE
CONTINUE DIALOGUE WITH THE
AUTHOR- BUT THE FEW OPTIONS
AVAILABLE THAT CAN COMPLY A
VIRTUALLY ALL WHITE. IN COLOR
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WERE
PUBLISHED. AB TWELVE TWENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. K. OPERATOR ARE
THERE ANY. OTHER ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES. WE WILL OPEN UP-
PARDON ME THERE ARE NO OTHER
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SEVEN
ONE FOUR THANK YOU MATTER- BUT
IT IS INTERESTING BUILT TO BE
QUITE HONEST WITH YOU BUT I AM
HAS THERE BEEN ANY. COST
ANALYSIS ON THIS- THE COST OF A
STANDARD ISSUE ROOF VERSUS WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE YEAH
IT'S BEEN QUITE A BIT OF
ANALYSIS SO IF IN FIRST YEAR
INCLUDING COST OF THESE ROOF
TECHNOLOGIES ARE NO DIFFERENT
ROOF. MATERIALS PLUS SAVINGS-
FROM A COOLING COSTS AND OTHER
SAVINGS AT FIFTY CENTS PER
SQUARE FOOT SAVED IN THE FIRST
YEAR AND THOSE ARE ON GOING
SAVINGS SO THE SAVINGS WOULD.
PROBABLY BE GREAT IN THE OUT
YEARS BECAUSE THAT FIRST YEAR
SAVINGS FACTORS IN THE COST OF
THE NEW MATERIAL HELLO THESE
PANELS LAST. A TYPICAL ROOFTOP
MATERIALS THROUGH THIRTY YEARS
YEAH IT'S THIS JUST A ANOTHER
REPORTER LIKE OTHERS. MR SAY ARE
TELL. IN A BAR MY CARE- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONCERNS ON THIS
ISSUE ONE OF THE ISSUES I HAVE
WITH THIS IN A LOT OF BILLS IS
YOU KNOW OF COURSE I SAID ON THE
HOUSING COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
SIDE. ALRIGHT COMMITTEE ALSO WE
HAVE THIS WE'RE TRYING HARD TO
ADDRESS ONE OF THE MOST IF NOT
THE SEX SECOND OR FIRST MOST
DIFFICULT ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO THAT ADDS
COST TO THAT HOUSING IS PILING
UP WERE AT FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A DOOR. TO
BUILD. AN AFFORDABLE UNIT. AND
THIS JUST KEEPS GOING UP AND I
REALIZE THAT THERE IS SOME TYPE
OF CAPTURE LATER ON. BUT IT'S
THE UP FRONT COST FOR A FAMILY
TO GET INTO A HOME. THESE THIS
THIS TYPE OF ISSUE IS GOING ARE
THESE TYPES OF PROJECTS- AND
ADDITIONS TO THE TO WHATEVER
HOUSE COSTS. IT SOMEDAY WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO PICK. WHAT DO WE
WANT PEOPLE TO BE ABLETO AFFORD
A HOUSE OR DO WE WANT A LITTLE
BIT LESSER OF THE TECHNOLOGY NOW
SO THEY CAN GET IN OR WE GONNA
DEMAND THE TECHNOLOGY AND PRICE
PEOPLE OUT. BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
OUR PRICING A MOUNTAIN AND OUR
KIDS ARE MOVING. BACK EAST AND
THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
GOING WITH THEM. BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO BE AWAY FROM THEIR
KIDS. SO THAT'S MY CONCERN WITH
THIS THIS BILL IN A LOT OF OTHER
BILLS. IS WE HAVE BUILT IN COSTS
THEY'RE GOING INTO THE HOUSE THE
PILING UP. AND INSTEAD OF
GETTING CLOSER TO AFFORDABLE.
WE'RE GETTING FARTHER AWAY. AND
WE'RE NEVER GOING TO FIX THIS
PROBLEM IF WE KEEP DOING. SO
THAT'S MY COMMENTS THANKS. AND-
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. I DON'T SEE
ANY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE IT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE A MOTION
AND I THINK A NUMBER OF- WE DO
OKAY WE HAVE A- MOTION AND A
SECOND- THE MOTION. IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE BEST HI RIVAS HI
FLORA. LARA KNOW BENNETT BENNETT
I GARCIA GARCIA I MATHIS.
MCCARTY. WHERE TO GI MURATSUCHI
I. REYES. REYES I SAY ARE DON'T
KNOW ZERO NO STONE. STONE I
WOULD. WHAT THANK YOU. CAN HAVE
A HOT SEVEN VOTES WILL BE THAT
OPEN THANKS THANKS. AND NOW OUR
FINAL BILL AB TEN SIXTY SEVEN
OUR AUTHOR IS- MR TANG BUT IT
WILL BE PRESENTED BY MR STONE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS FIRST MR TANG
APPRECIATES THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE BY- STAFF BUT WITH HIS
STAFF AND HE'S HAPPY TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE OFFERED
THIS IS ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S
BOTTLE BUILT CANS
IMPLEMENTATIONS OF COURSE WAS A
BILL THAT WAS. PUT IN PLACE FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS AGO. AND THIS
LEGISLATORS BEEN WORKING TO TRY
TO UPDATE IT OVER THE YEARS WITH
VERY LIMITED SUCCESS AND ONE OF
THEISSUES THOUGH. THAT HAVE.
REALLY STARTS TO SHOW ITSELF
MORE AND MORE AND MORE IS THE
NOTION OF THE PENALTY THAT GETS
PAID. BY A LOT OF THE LARGER
RETAILERS WHO INSTEAD OF TAKING
BACK BOTTLES UNDER THE C. R. V.
PROGRAM ARE JUST HAPPY TO PAY
THE PENALTIES. AND THAT THERE'S
A COUPLE THINGS ONE IS WE MISS
THEIR PARTICIPATION. BUT THE
OTHERS THEN IT PUSHES ONTO THE
SMALLER RETAILERS IN THE SAME
AREA WHO DON'T HAVE THE LUXURY
OF BEING ABLE JUST TO PAY THE
PENALTIES. AND THEN THERE
OBLIGATION THEY'RE TAKING BACK A
LOT OF THESE MATERIALS IS HIS
EXACERBATED AND IN AREAS LIKE
MINE THIS IS BECOME A REAL A
REAL ISSUE WHERE WE HAVE VERY
HIGH LEVELS OF CURBSIDE
RECYCLING. THEN THE IMPACT ON
THE- FORCING THE SMALLER
RETAILERS TO TAKE BACK A LOT OF
THE CRB MATERIALS IT BECOMES AN
EXTRAORDINARY BURDEN ON THEM
EVEN WHEN WE HAVE VERY HIGH
SUCCESS RATES AND VERY HIGH
LEVELS OF RECYCLING SO THE
IMPACT OF THIS SYRUPY FEE IS
DIFFERENT DEPENDING ON THE AREAS
THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO IMPLEMENT.
AND WE'VE TRIED OFTENTIMES TO
REALLY LOOK AT HOW WE CAN BRING
THIS TO BE PROGRAM UP TO SPEED
AND THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
CONTINUALLY PUSHED BACK AND NOT
REALLY WANTING TO LOOK AT WHAT
HAS BEEN PROPOSED BEFORE SO WHAT
BETTER THINGS BILL DOES TEN TEN
SIXTY SEVEN. AS A REQUIRES A
STUDY AND I THINK IT IS LONG
PAST TIME THAT WE GET DATA OUT
OF CAL RECYCLE TO LET US KNOW
HOW THE PROGRAM AND WORKING WHAT
THE IMPACTS ARE WHAT THE
DISPARITIES ARE BETWEEN LARGE
LARGE RETAILERS SMALL RETAILERS
ESPECIALLY IN SOME OF THE
SMALLER AREAS THE DIFFERENCES IN
THOSE AREAS THAT HAVE HIGH
LEVELS OF RECYCLING ALREADY AND
LESS LEVELS OF RECYCLING AND HOW
WE CAN MAKE THIS THE BEST
INCENTIVE POSSIBLE. AS IT WAS
ORIGINALLY INTENDED AND THAT'S
WHAT MR KING'S BILL DOES AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON. B. TEN
SIXTY. THERE IS A WITNESS I
BELIEVE MARK MURRAY FROM
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE. AND
WITHOUT I ASK THAT THE WITNESS
BE ABLE TO PRESENT AND ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE SHARE. OPERATOR KEEP
THESE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR- MARC
MURRAY FROM CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE OF. BOB YOUR MEMBERS MARK
MURRAY WITH CALIFORNIA AGAINST
WASTE IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE HAS
CAPTURED THE ISSUE PERFECTLY
THERE ARE NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE INADEQUATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR REDEMPTION
RECYCLING THE FAIL SAFE IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE IN STORE
REDEMPTION BUT THE FAIL SAFE
ABOUT DATED AND FAILING- AB TEN
SIXTY SEVEN PROPOSES A POP
BOTTLE PROCESS FOR ANALYZING THE
ISSUE RIGHT SIZING IN STORE
REDEMPTION AND PAYMENT SYSTEM TO
CREATE REAL INCENTIVES FOR
COMMUNITY BASED RECYCLING
CENTRES WITHOUT BURDENING SMALL
MOM AND POP STORES WITH NO
OBLIGATION THAT THEY CANNOT
AFFORD TO PAY. WE URGE YOU NOT
VOTE. THANK YOU WE DON'T HAVE
ANY WITNESSES REGISTER IN
OPPOSITION- BUT WE WILL TAKE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES STARTING
WITH ANY IN THE HEARING ROOM. C.
N. NON OF OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. OF AB TEN SIXTY
SEVEN. AND TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB TEN SIXTY
SEVEN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS
TIME. THE FIRST GO TO LINES
SEVENTY TWO GO AHEAD PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES OF LOUIS BROWN WITH
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
WE DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THE BILL AT THIS
TIME- BUT DO X. APPRECIATE THE
WORK TO THE COMMITTEE IS DONE-
WE HAVE SPOKEN WITH THE AUTHOR
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR ON THIS ISSUE.
HI ASK STATED BY MR MURRAY- WE
DO THINK THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE FURTHER ANALYZED IT
IS SIMPLY A PIECE OF THE BOTTLE
BILL THAT JUST DOESN'T WORK IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS WITH A NUMBER OF
IDEAS HOW TO IMPROVE THE ABILITY
TO RESPECT FOR CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA MAKE SURE THAT THEY
RECEIVE THE REDEMPTION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR ATTENTION
TODAY. AND AGAIN AT THIRTY
OTHERS IN FAVOR OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU I'M ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. YOU SEE NINE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU I OBSERVE THE
MOTION I WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS RIVAS HI RIVAS
HI FLORA. FLOOR NO BENNETT.
BENNETT I GARCIA. GARCIA I
MATHIS MCCARTY. WHERE TO CHECK
WHERE TO CHECK A RADIUS HI RES
ICY ARCTIC. STONE HI STONE I
WOULD. I. THE BILL HAS SEVEN
VOTES SO NEXT WE WILL OR CALL IF
ANYONE NEEDS TO ADD ON A BIT
BELIEVES WE HAVE A FEW MEMBERS
THE NEW TO ADD ON TO BILLS OR DO
WE HAVE ANY BILLS ON CALL. OKAY
OKAY. SO WANT TO START FROM WE
WILL START FROM THE BEGINNING.
THE SIMPSONS. SIXTY NINE OKAY AB
ITEM TO AB THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CHERVONA OF.
CALDERON RIVAS I REQUEST I
MATHIS. SZIJJARTO NOW SEE ART OF
NO. EIGHT CAPITAL HAS EIGHT
VOTES AND IT'S OUT. AB FIVE
TWENTY TWO. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING I.
BENNETT. SIERRA FIVE ZERO HI.
NINETY ONE. AB. FIFTEEN
NINETEEN. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING NO. CESARO I SEE
YOUR- FIVE IT'S FOR. TO FIVE.
OKAY THE BILL ONLY HAS FOUR
VOTES FOR SALES. NINE FOUR
THREE. AB FIVE NINE FOUR THREE
THE MOTION AS DEPRESSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR
VOTING HI SAGARA NOW. C. R. O.
NO. THE BILL HAS EIGHT BOTH
SOUTH. SIX AB. ONE THOUSAND ONE.
OKAY SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING I. MATHIS. EIGHT
THE BILL HAS A BOTH SENT OUT.
NEXT IS ACR ONE OH NINE THE
MOTION IS TO IS TO BE ADOPTED AS
AMENDED- CHAIR VOTING ICY ARCTIC
HI. ZERO I. AB RIGHT KOLAPO
CENTER NUMBER FROM THE FRONT OF
IT OKAY ELEVEN THE BILL IS OUT.
AB TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING I.
RT HI RT I. OKAY THE BILL HAS A
BOTH WTHOUT AB ELEVEN FIFTY
FOUR. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO RE REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING I
SEE ARTICLE HI. ZERO I. THE BILL
HAS TEN VOTES OUT. AB TEN
SEVENTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS- TO
PASS AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CHAIR VOTING I SEE
GARDEN HI. ZERO I. THE BILL HAS
SEVEN BOTH STYLE. AND AB TEN
SIXTY SEVEN. THE MOTION AS
DEPRESSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING I.
MCCARTY HI MCCARTY I SEE ARTICLE
NUMBER. THE BILL HAS EIGHT BOTH
HIMSELF THE CONSENT CALENDAR
OKAY OKAY SO. NEXT CAN SECONDARY. ABSENT MEMBERS S. C. GARDEN HI
ZERO HI. I THINK WE'RE DONE THE
MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU.